Thank you.
for everybody here first we do have a subcommittee first this morning which is dealing with the the bill which we have on the university college system that we will do first and of course and then chair that is Oliver Ford here represent Ford we do have some amending language and he's going to be opening that up when we conclude this then we go into the executive sessions Thank you.
So what we've done is that we've taken the bill that was initially put forward by Representative Ford and addressed the issue that can the associate's degree that you earn at the community college level can you use those credits and everything you've done through that degree and come into the university system being Keene State, Plymouth State and UNH and Granite State merging in with UNH Manchester can you use those credits and come as a junior?
Well, we looked at that and copied law that came out of Tennessee.
Since then, and throughout this process, the subcommittee's been working vigorously with the university system and the community college system to look at all the articulation agreements which we have between community college and university system.
And there's a lot of issues that I've found along the way that this giant leap that we are taking maybe needs to be refined, maybe needs to be retooled a little bit, but everybody's anxious to try and get credit stackable from one level to another level and get the common understandings that this basic course right here may be applied as a general ed course in a university system as well.
And those agreements, we have many, many articulation agreements now between the two systems.
Part of the problem we found out during the study is the two systems are all operating on different software, which makes it extremely difficult to have something automatically go from here to there.
So, and the systems are working on that.
What I'd like to do, we've had input from, regarding this amendment, it's come from both Mark Rubinstein, who's's here from the community college system and the Board of Presidents and the trustees and and Kathy Provincia has been very involved with that level where this through our university system meeting we had on has been well well received by the trustees they recognize this is the direction we need to be moving in.
They also very much appreciate what we did with Granite State College and that merger process.
Those are all part of their initiatives to try to look at the structure and organization of how we're functioning in higher education today.
And there's a lot going on there so this bill right here provides the the transfer pathways that we need in order to get credit from one system to another system and approve so a student doesn't lose 25% what they did in the community college system so that they don't lose this time this money and and have some of these courses show up all that doesn't count towards our program we want to get better communication and so before I go any more with this perhaps mr.
chair that you'd want to have some input maybe from Catherine Fincher or mark Rubenstein in regard to the amendment, where they are on it, if they feel comfortable with this or not.
Good morning, Mr.
Chair and members of the committee.
The community college system and university system have worked closely together over the past two to three weeks.
We've done research into the Tennessee law and the Tennessee history.
That was the basis of the last proposed amendment that came forward.
Had lots of discussions about the previous language was that all associates degrees would transfer in, but not all associates degrees are intended to be transferable, if you will.
So the language that we've worked on, and we've pulled in the provost at the university system, we're all really committed to moving this forward.
And so I definitely...
And so identifying the 30 top majors to really benefit our community college students and have a universal agreement between the community college system and the university system so there aren't't hundreds of articulation agreements, will identify the 30 top transfer pathways and have a universal agreement between the seven institutions at the community college system and the, I'll say, three and a half right now because of the Granite State-UNH merger process.
And have that universal agreement in place for at least 30 programs no later than July 1st of 2024.
It's going to take some work in both systems to make sure we can get that universal language that's hopefully seamless for our students.
Thank you.
Good morning, Mr.
Chair, members of the committee.
As Chief Administrative Officer Preventure described, we've been working collaboratively on this for a while now.
And a couple of things I'd like to highlight in the language that we've come up with.
You'll note that the 30 programs that are described on line 18, for which the demand from students in the community college system is the highest.
The rationale for that language was with thought because it allows us to identify where our students want to go.
It allows us to tailor the demand among our students across the university system because if we simply did where the largest enrollments were, they would tend to concentrate primarily with UNH.
Nothing wrong with that except that for a lot of our students in the North Country and other parts of the state their ambitions and where they best will be fulfilled would align with work being done at Plymouth or Keene so the intent was to make sure that this was driven by the demand from the community college students the other piece you'll see in there on line 16 reference to optimizing utility and affordability in some states there's a mandate that an associate degree is 60 credits and a bachelor's degree is 120 we don't have that and so for a lot of our students the ability to complete an associate degree may be 66 or 68 or 70 credits in doing that they're continuing to benefit from the lower tuition and the more accessible locations, the community college system.
And part of this language was intended to say, let's allow students not simply to think about 60 credits and an associate degree, but as much of the educational opportunities as they can take advantage of the community college system and then partner with the university system to complete that.
And specifically, the reference to the utility of the community college system, Twelve instructional locations around the state, in some cases similar to what President Lloyd from White Mountains has done with Plymouth, being able to complete bachelor's degree on-site in locations that are more accessible and more familiar.
So this was really crafted with thoughtful intent to try and align with the needs that our students, the students served by the community college system, to allow them to benefit from what the university system offers, but in ways that are more accessible to them.
Thank you.
but it starts with getting students as well as kindergarten to understand the mistake is to get to that.
That is to begin to build a ladder.
And the ladder goes all the way to the university.
And so we're seeing that as part of the way of selling this idea to students who probably haven't thought of the university yet.
They never think about how do I get a job.
And so they go to the community college and they take over.
Thank you.
for students who probably haven't thought of the university yet.
They never, they're just thinking about how do I get a job?
And so they go to the community college and they say, okay, we want to maybe do something like, these are just ideas going out there, who will enroll?
So that any student who enrolls in the community college also enrolls in, say, Granite State.
I believe now they can't realize there's some people problem in her.
But fortunately, one of the former directors of Granite State, Thank you.
That was not perhaps the name was to say, look, you're admitted to the community college.
You're also admitted to the university.
So that creates a reminder of students to come and continue.
Not I'm in an end game.
I go here, I graduate, I get a job.
But I go here, I grow, I get a job, and I continue.
Oh, And that's a different mindset.
And so now we can have complete college as a model.
And so complete college for manager then becomes the thing that creates the momentum in the student's mind.
Creates the expectation of more.
This is really better.
And of course we've got, as you Chair.
Just a quick question about the 30 majors.
Do you have some sense of what those are?
Do you have data so you know where you're going or starting from scratch and trying to figure that out?
We currently do, and there's a fair amount of stability to it.
A lot of them will be in programs.
Our single largest enrollment in terms of degree completion in the community college system over the last decade has been nursing.
And so we already have bachelor's completion programs, liberal arts, business.
So the top five, top ten are relatively consistent.
In fact, the top 20, one of the things that we'll want to be able to do, though, is take a look college by college to make sure that, again, the large isn't overshadowing the importance of regional differentiation.
So we've got good data on what the demand has been and we're going to have to see if over time that shifts and make sure we don't overshadow you know smaller regional commitments.
Thank you.
You're welcome sir.
I'm not sharing this one.
Thanks very much, Oliver.
And I think sort of following on Art's question about the 30 undergraduate majors at the community college level, but I'm sort of interested in sort of a tangential thing.
How many majors approximately do we have at the community college associates level that have no transferability or continuity into the four-year system?
I'm reluctant to say no transferability, but in terms of tendency, likelihood, last year we offered over 150 distinct associate degree and certificate programs.
I would venture to say that a fair number of those are certificate programs.
Massage therapy might be an example.
Does it mean that there's not a bachelor's completion opportunity for somebody who completes a certificate or an associate degree, but ultimately wants to be a sole proprietor and may want a business degree?
So almost any of the programs could, But what we're focused on with those 30 are primarily going to be programs that have a strong foundation that that points in the direction of probable transfer so in a follow-up on that the the you know the reason I'm asking I'm not sure if this is still the case but it certainly was sort of pre-COVID where where there was was a significant amount of marketing being done by out-of-state institutions at our community colleges to try to pick up, you know, students who may want to continue into a bachelor's program outside of New Hampshire.
And so I think this is a great opportunity here to sort of get out in front of that and say oh no your opportunities are right here in New Hampshire but beyond the 30 that have sort of very direct pathways you know I think it would be interesting also to consider a you know I think that Maybe the terminal degree is an associate's degree or is a certificate program, but these students may want to continue and may want to apply those classes towards general education.
And it would seem like the structure of this would support that type of transferability as well, should the community college and the university system identify those opportunities.
I think that that's right, Representative Luna.
I think our underlying thought about all of this is that life is ideally long and complicated, maybe not ideally complicated, but it is.
And people don't always take a straight line to where they need to get to or where they need to get to changes over time.
We want to optimize the flexibility, the utility, the value that students have.
Again, Representative Ford was describing Complete College New Hampshire as a concept of, you know, K through 20 plus.
For a lot of the students who will be serving, they're long since past 20 plus.
They're coming back looking for something different that they need to find in their lives.
And we want to optimize flexibility for all of those students.
Could I also add, there's a real commitment on the part of the university system and the community college system.
This is a start, right?
It says at least 30.
The chancellor and I have biweekly meetings.
We were just talking at our last meeting about running start and how do we really strategically leverage the benefit of that in the high schools to for a transfer to community college and and beyond there's a lot going on between the two systems in addition to to this work here so again I just want to make certain that folks recognize that there's a commitment on on the part of both to really start partnering on at a lot of different levels.
Thank you.
On the complexities of life issue, I think there are a number of people that, like you said, start maybe community college or even maybe start the university and then drop out and then you know have their family or whatever and then want to go back so if if somebody got an associates degree that's it is there like a retroactive so that if you had it if you received your associate degree maybe 10 years ago at a community college, and now you want to go into the university, do you come in as a junior?
I mean, I know that some colleges have a time limit on how far back they'll accept credits from other institutions.
Some of those more complicated situations, it does still have to be a little bit case by case.
Without getting to the extreme of a computer science degree from 1974, that may be a little bit different than it would be in 2020.
Although some of the foundational principles might still still be the same again case by case typically the the issue is going to be you know a student's not likely to lose all of that if it's a completed associate degree but it really will depend on the applicability and the foundation that provides I don't believe in the university system there's an interest in simply selling more credits, requiring a student to repeat work that they can demonstrate.
And there are a number of vehicles, credit by examination would be one of those, to try and ensure that a student doesn't have to repeat work for which they can demonstrate that they still have the foundational knowledge that they build on for the bachelor's degree.
So on page one, the 24, 25, 26 line, where it says that enrolled in a pathway shall be deemed to have met all general education and lower division requirements.
Again, if another industry maybe is health care and nursing, things change pretty rapidly sometimes in that particular area as well.
Is there a time limit on completing one and being accepted as a junior at the other?
Assuming this language is adopted, I would think that one of the things that we normally think about when a student enrolls they enroll in a catalog year catalog is published here are the guidelines here the requirements for your degree as long as a student maintains continuous enrollment then the student is typically deemed to be will honor that commitment so I think that that in my experience with transfer pathways between institutions, it's been similar.
When the agreements are struck that a student who begins enrollment at an institution under that pathway, as long as they maintain continuous enrollment, even on a part-time basis, and at a fairly slow but steady pace, that we still honor those commitments.
Thank you very much, Mark.
Catherine.
that we still honor those commitments.
Thank you very much, Mark.
Catherine, the other day when we were in Keene on Thursday and Friday, there was much discussion dealing with structure and organization.
And as I've gotten into this, and I'm just on the fringe side looking in and trying to become more knowledgeable and understanding some of those issues which are confronting the systems in terms of engaging in the processes that are laid out here, this is a step forward.
It's certainly not the end of it.
What are some of the significant issues which we're going to have to overcome in order to really get, I think, where everybody wants to get from, you know, the management side to the technology side?
What are some of those issues which are really hindering us in the stackable credit type concept where all engaged in trying to move towards?
I'll speak just for the university system.
You mentioned it earlier, Representative Ladd.
Technology is a barrier.
And the university system is about to embark on a massive project for a new ERP enterprise resource planning system for the student side finance human resources right now again on the university system side our student systems can't talk to one another.
And it makes it challenging to even seamlessly transfer credits from Plymouth to UNH.
So we recognize this as a barrier, committed to overcoming that.
It is a huge project, costly project, but there's commitment to ensure that we see the finish line on that because that's where that's where we have to head right that's where the public higher education in New Hampshire must head As as you well know representative lad our board of trustees voted on Thursday to name the president of UNH, President Jim Dean, also as interim chancellor and to review that in no more than two years to drive the work of shared student-facing services across the university system.
I've been very involved in the administrative, sharing all of the administrative services across the university system but president Dean and the other presidents president Treadwell and President Burks will lead the sharing of I call them student facing services in the coming year or two as as we move forward so and that refers to structural flexibility and transition right now as we think about the significant headwinds, demographic headwinds that we'll be facing by the time we get to 2025, 2026.
If I might add a couple of other thoughts.
We talked about stackable credentials.
A lot of those credentials are not authored by the community college system or the university system.
They're delivered by industry, by other agents, and creating a useful universal repository for those things to have sort of a credential database, if you will, so that employer-issued or industry-issued certifications and credentials and ones that we offer, as does the university system, that a student can have that type of a digital platform and portfolio to take that education wherever they may get the education to wherever they may need to deliver the education.
So I think that's one of the resources.
Dr.
Fisher at NHTI and Dr.
LaValle at UNH are collaborating on a proposal we hope to bring forward shortly looking to create a statewide repository for that type of digital credential that I think will benefit the entire state and employers and industries in New Hampshire.
The other piece in terms of what we're looking at, I've focused on sort of the older student, but looking back to what Representative Ford described about K-through, New Hampshire is increasingly diverse, and one of the data points I may have shared with this committee in the past, it stays with me often.
Prior to the pandemic in the 2019-2020 school year, even though it had gotten a little bit better, percentage of New Hampshire students grades 1 through 12 on free and reduced lunch, still about 25%, and grades 1 through 8 still about 28% in that year.
The data have gotten a little bit strange because of changes made to the program in the pandemic but you look at Berlin you look at Laconia look at Rochester You look at Nashua all of those school districts serving students where 40% of the students on free and reduced lunch in the 1920 school year you look at Concord a third of the students state capital a third of the students at Manchester, over 50% of the students.
This is the future of New Hampshire's population, its workforce over the next generation.
Right now their parents are in the workforce and are eligible for that service.
This is the future and we've got to make sure that they are not excluded, that they don't feel left behind.
When we talk about whether college is possible, price can can't be a barrier cost can't be a barrier we've got to show them that their pathways to get there and we've got to actually make that real as they progress through high school we've got a running start program allow students to take college courses while in high school contribute to the affordability but they have to see that that's not just a course that that's a stepping stepping stone to what comes next.
We've got to do a better job of building out that pathway.
And if I might follow up with that a little bit with a question.
With that poverty level we have throughout the state and in places where you wouldn't assume there would be that much like a third or even more than that, and those that are going on on this pathway into a two-year or four-year type program Thank you.
or even more than that.
And those that are going on on this pathway into a two-year or four-year type program or some kind of certification, it takes dollars to do that.
And with this shrinking demographic we have in the state and the marketing being done by those that are competing with us from outside, and we saw a list of those on Thursday and Friday that are challenging Keene and challenging Plymouth State and challenging UNH.
We need to attract these students.
So what we are doing, we're giving scholarship money to the, not giving, well granting scholarship money to allow some of these students to come to the higher education level.
That creates a real expense issue associated with revenue.
Where is the dollar coming from?
And we talk in this program right here, the challenges associated with the dollars that are needed to get everybody on the same page in terms of application software, which is, I would, we're talking huge huge dollars way up in the millions of dollars so for us to be sustainable the competing against those others that are marketing against us and challenging us and taking students away from this state how can the legislature help you accomplish what you're trying to do here?
This is just the edge of it right here in this bill.
What do we have to do?
Go for it, Catherine.
I can see you churning.
We need more funding.
Yeah.
Even one-time funding would help with some of these.
This ERP project, we're projecting over the next five years, that could cost the university system $25 to $30 million.
And we're working on ways to identify funding sources.
That's one example.
Chancellor Rubinstein mentioned the repository.
And again, community college system, university system working on that.
I think even the Department of Education is being pulled into that.
That's going to require resources.
And Chancellor Rubinstein and Representative Ladd, you mentioned our neediest New Hampshire students if you are Pell eligible and a New Hampshire resident Pell eligible is a federal scholarship program federally funded scholarship program for for needy students if you're Pell eligible in a New Hampshire resident you receive free tuition at all of our institutions and and those dollars those last dollar scholarships are funded through the university system.
So these are all necessary.
and those dollars, those last dollar scholarships are funded through the university system.
So these are all necessary costs that we need to incur to deliver on our mission, but it puts incredible pressure on the ability to continue to deliver affordable and accessible quality education for our students the granted get the granted guarantee program that I referred to as a last dollar scholarship so you'd first apply your Pell Grant and then and then the grant a guarantee do you you need anything, Representative Rubenstein?
Chancellor Rubenstein?
I'm reluctant to ask for money at this point.
In part, it's what you have available, but I'm not sure that that's what changes the dynamic.
New Hampshire for years has been characterized as the leading exporter on a percentage basis of college-bound seniors looking for four-year institutions, and that's not necessarily a dollar issue as much as it's a perception and attitude issue.
I think that the investments that Ms.
Provencher describes are ones that would not so much just produce the impact of the spending, but create a perception that the systems are valued.
One of the things that I think that we've got to continue to work on is figuring out how to collaborate, not compete with each other.
I think that's true within systems.
I think it's true between systems.
And it may not be intentional, but I think it's still an outcome that we've got to try and figure out a better way to do.
How do we focus resources, create the most efficiency, the most high-quality programs we can with less duplication where it's not helpful?
So, again, I think some of this is maybe more things that we need to work on internally.
But the investments that the legislature makes are perhaps investments that are also endorsements, that change the way people perceive.
Several years ago, the legislature introduced scholarships.
Running Start costs a student $50 per credit, a three-credit course, $150.
But the legislature invested in scholarships for students in STEM courses.
STEM STEM is certainly important but it's not the only part of the curriculum and so maybe that's another opportunity to invest to reinforce in the value that getting an early start on college for those who are able and motivated and want to capitalize on the affordability gives them more reason and you build out these pathways that we've been talking about in a a student who finishes high school, not with two or three running start courses, but with a year's worth of college, sees a very affordable, very sensible pathway to finish the associate degree and then go on to a bachelor's without leaving the borders of the state for post-secondary education.
Thank you.
We've had a wonderful discussion on the STEM and why we're not involving other courses of study.
And I think the dollar has restricted us to STEM.
Thanks, Oliver.
And to Mark, to your and Catherine's just prior comments, I think it is important that the systems work together to reduce inefficiencies.
But at the same time, the community college mission leading with access, and that's why seven colleges spread throughout the state.
And even satellite campuses beyond that, such as White Mountains, provides that level of high-quality educational experience in my hometown.
And one of the things and and you know we talked about this I think a little bit last week at the NHTI advisory board meeting which is the the really the almost the disappearance of of on-site engineering technology programs here in Concord and and instead, students, NHTI students in Concord are traveling down to Manchester to do associate's programs.
While that's not, you know, for many of us, we don't think traveling from Concord to Manchester is very difficult, but for a lot of students, so we've got a lot of new Americans in the Concord area, any time they have to travel, you know, much beyond downtown becomes an obstacle.
And while, you know, it may be efficient, given that the university system is now offering a four-year program in engineering technology out of University of New Hampshire-Manchester campus.
Having those first two years available through NHTI and other community colleges in my hometown gives me the option of, oh, I can sort of take that program and then later on decide if I want to continue with it.
I may not even want to continue with a four-year program right away.
I might want to go into industry for a few years and put that NHTI engineering technology degree to work and then see where I want to go with it.
So I would just sort of want to put out a caution on the efficiency side because I think it's such an important role that our community colleges play in keeping students here in New Hampshire and attracting them to programs that they might not otherwise be considering if they had to travel much beyond their hometown to get there.
Your point is well made, Representative Luno.
I believe, and if I did not, I intended to say that duplication without adding value for students, that there are places where we will have mirrored programs, but it makes sense for purpose.
I'll also, if you don't mind, use the opportunity to add one more thing about what I think this committee, what the legislature can do.
You already invest in the community college system, the university system.
We're a resource for this state to the extent that there are state agencies that have direct workforce needs or state agencies who are responsible for serving the citizens of New Hampshire, where you can identify opportunities where we can strengthen the work they do through collaboration.
It also strengthens our mission.
So, again, thinking of us as top of mind, when you've got a problem you're trying to solve with agencies throughout the state.
How can public higher education be of service?
Absolutely.
Especially our students.
We find our students are definitely more drawn to paid internships, right?
Because it's...
Absolutely.
So paid internships is a great opportunity if there are opportunities in state government for community college students or university system students.
internships is a great opportunity if there are opportunities in state government for community college students or university system students Please understand that I come to this problem of personal media.
My wife went to the three-year college before moving on to the three-year college, before marrying and having children moving all the way up to the doctor.
So I know how it works.
I know all they have to put into it.
I tried to babysit a one-year-old in the library.
But I'll never do it again.
But I also have a daughter in college.
She dropped out of college in New York, married my son, We can floor.
Thank you.
And I appreciate all the work that you do.
Anyone else?
If you want to add something from another perspective, having been a college president, I know there's also another perspective.
I think it's a little bit covered.
I think it's a little having a student information system that is compatible across the system.
I think we have that now at the community college.
And I think Ross could tell, that was a leading effort from the prior chancellor.
And so I think we do have some probably good data, good information at this time in terms of how that has improved movement within the community college system.
And hopefully we can use that data to help provide the resources that we need at the university system to complete a similar type, you know, yet obviously more expansive, extensive project.
I have one last comment, just sort of wrapping it up.
About a year and a half ago, it was in March 2021, I think, that we discussed merger here in the House and the governor, et cetera.
And that is an issue which is still there one of which the we had a subcommittee put together some 30 to 40 odd questions or concerns and so I'd like to just to communicate that the legislature is still very interested in working with the university system, the community college system, in working towards the efficiencies and streamlining our higher education system, which we know we have to do.
I fear that within the next five years, we're looking at extinction in some of our higher education programming, our competitors out there are eating our lunch.
And unless we can address this whole system of efficiencies and working cooperatively together, I think we're going to lose a lot of our students in the state to others.
And therefore, we won't have the students operate our own system and so we're at that i think we're at a critical mass point right now when i look at the margin versus where our revenues are and what our expenses are we're we're there we're eating up some of our resources we have to continue marching the way we're marching if there's any comments on that but i just want to say we we want to work with you I would just add that and representative I think you would concur that our board talked about this a little bit around the edges last week and and if there if there if that is a reasonable path forward, maybe there should be an outside expert funding for that to really examine and assess the opportunities between the two systems.
I'm just not sure that within internally if that might create more conflict where an outside expert that maybe had been through this before could answer some of the questions that your subcommittee had posed and there were as you mentioned 30 to 40 of those questions.
So if that conversation is still on the table, the legislature, the governor, may want to consider funding some type of outside study to really dig into that.
I'd like to tack on one thing that I see is why.
It's always been struck by this education, Thank you.
It doesn't have the assurance that I can do this.
But I have perhaps that advantage.
I have an English degree.
I also have a degree in international physics.
And then I have a master's degree.
I have a doctorate.
I don't want to become a university president.
I don't think you want to be educating a lot of universities.
It's just not fair.
Thank you.
Some of those kids don't know that they don't speak English.
They haven't figured it out yet.
We have to find ways for them also to be recognized just because they're not in position.
They may need even more opportunities to challenge.
So let's keep it easy.
One of the problems that we're talking about, maybe the people who are without it, we don't know where it's going.
We don't feel like we're alive.
We don't have time.
Anyone else?
We very much appreciate your continued support and interest in furthering our partnerships across the state.
Okay, Mr.
Chair, what we need to do is that if we're at the point on this subcommittee where we're ready to make a recommendation back to the full committee, I think a motion has to be brought forward.
I'll move we recommend ought to pass on the amendment to 1530, amendment 947.
I'll second it.
No, it'd be the subcommittee members that are voting on this.
So Art, you, me, Alicia, and you.
Okay.
All in favor, raise your hand.
Thank you.
Thank you very much, everybody from the college and university system.
Yeah, what we have to do now is just open up the full body.
Thank you very much.
This is a huge issue, the university and community college system.
It's big on our platteratter just like a third party to come in and look at just our facilities what do we tear down what do we renovate all that from the various campuses we have a huge need architects involved you need to have engineers involved you need to have good accounting involved.
And it's a huge, huge, huge dollar we're looking at.
We're just looking at a small fraction of the academic side.
But right now we have an interim chancellor at the four-year system.
We have a chancellor at the community college system who's also acting as president in HTI right now so we're at a time when we're doing a lot of movement and transitioning it's optimal for us to really be looking at the big picture So with that.
Mr.
Chair, I have a final follow-up question, if you will.
I wonder if we're in a position now for us to consider undertaking a kind of joint study kind of thing, formalizing it in that way, to look at the issues as we see them and then bounce that off of them again and say, all right, this is what we're seeing.
What else do we need to be looking at?
But maybe go to places like Excel and Ed and the American Council on Education and find out sources from those people who might be able to guide us in this process.
Well, what we got right now, we have a higher education study committee by statute.
This year it's headed headed up by Senator Ruth Ward that committee has the responsibility for doing just what you you said okay this committee can make recommendations and talk with the higher education study committee and bring some of our findings to that body that body then is working directly with the two systems and so it's time for us to really activate the study committee and get it really moving and discussing we're not going to get to where we need to get unless the university system the community college system and the legislature are talking with each other yes it's just it's it's a huge issue we have here I suppose as a is an office in this business I'm asking you what is our next best step and should we formalize that committee as a recommendation from this subcommittee to I think this subcommittee is addressing a specific bill okay we were looking at credits and the associate's degree as related to a bachelor's degree.
Right.
We've come up with a recommendation.
I think it's a good starting step.
We're certainly not there.
We need to continue with this perspective and this agenda.
But to get into the larger realm here, which is a huge, huge topic, I think that are working directly with the higher education study committee is the best way and to be working with the two systems and we have people on this this committee right here that are involved with either as trustees or board members that we can convey that message that we want to work cooperatively together.
Does the amendment we've just passed give us a place to stand on to go forward with that, I guess is what I'm asking.
I think that amendment is along the lines of the academic side of things which we're looking at.
I don't think it gives us any other than what we found through our studying and through working with Excel Ed, Excellent Ed, when we dealt with them on the Tennessee legislation.
I think they can engage too.
But there's a lot going on on the higher education levels with the management there, the governance.
They're working on this.
There's a lot going on.
and I was very surprised to hear some of the issues which are being discussed right now.
And they've already invested millions of dollars towards this effort of trying to streamline our two systems and to protect our higher education in this state, not to see our kids leaving the state and going to Community College in Massachusetts or to the University of Maine for the four-year degrees.
And we're under attack from those other two systems right now.
Oh, no question.
So, as far as this is, I think what we need is to act on this, and we need to communicate verbally with our Higher Education Study Committee, Representative Ward and others around that.
Lou DeAlexander is also on that.
Talk with these folks and make them aware of what we're learning.
Anything else?
We're going into executive session on this one first?
Yeah, that's what we'll do first.
Yeah, and then...
So I'd like to bring the Education Committee to order here.
We are now in executive session.
The first bill we're going to exact is 1530.
I'd like to make a motion and I'll hand the gavel over to Representative Cordelli.
Thank you.
To move 1530.
Yes.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I will recognize Chairman Ladd for a motion related to House Bill 1530 relative to bachelor's degrees offered by the Community College System of New Hampshire.
And I move ought to pass.
Second.
represent of Luno and comments chairman land yes I'd like to further make the motion to move amendment zero nine four seven H referencing establishing curricular transfer pathways between the community college system of New Hampshire and the university system of New Hampshire I'll second that second by representative Luno discussion on the amendment I have no further discussion after the subcommittee discussion earlier yes right further discussion great excuse me do we have copies of the amendment they're there are copies up here they were passed out earlier let's see here do we have it when we had the subcommittee that I think they were taken around to everybody here's another one right here thank you Thank you.
We had a pretty healthy discussion on this during the subcommittee meeting.
We started at 9 o'clock and went through 10 o'clock.
It's a first step.
This is not not the end all but it is a definite first step where we're trying to identify articulation agreements in 30 programs according to this undergraduate majors which will transfer between the community college system and the university system New Hampshire and eliminate that issue where we now have some students coming out of the community college system wanting to get into a pathway and they're losing 25% of the money they put in their program already those 25% may not even transfer and that's disappointing so our effort is to try to get this so we do have this stackable type credit going all the way through as as Representative Ford has mentioned.
We want to have this concept of K through, right through the higher education system, whether we're talking with each other.
And unfortunately, we can't talk with each other on the higher education system because we're all on different platforms in terms of software we're using between these programs.
Keynes's on here, Plymouth's over here, UNH is over here.
They're all not communicating or talking with each other, along with these seven community college, which are on the same platform, but that platform's not talking to the university system platform.
So we want to move forward and get beyond this and and and help our kids in the state stay in the state and not leave for what they think is greener ground somewhere else and if I if I may I think an important part of this amendment too is is that it was developed specifically in collaboration with the community college system and the university system.
In fact, they essentially wrote the amendment here.
So the testimony we heard this morning during the subcommittee was very much in support both by the university system the community college system to move this this joint effort forward any further comments seen none yeah right I'm just waiting for the clerk to return to see so this Thank you.
unanimous mr.
clerk do we have the names of all the people which are subbing in here today?
Yeah, he has them.
You have that?
Yes, and this will be a roll call vote on ought to pass as amended for House Bill 1530.
Okay, I'm going to fill some names here.
And do we have a motion on the table to do?
Yeah, yeah, it's a cell rate.
Yeah.
Okay.
Representative Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Lang.
Representative Boehm.
Yes.
Representative Leekas.
Representative Sela.
Yes.
All right.
Okay.
Hopsin.
Representative Hopsin.
Yes.
Representative Ford.
Representative Soda.
Yes.
Representative Nelson.
Representative Walner.
Yes.
Representative Luna.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Ellison.
Yes.
Representative Mullen.
Representative Woodcock.
Murray.
Oh, I'm sorry, Murray.
Yes.
Representative Porter.
Representative Paul.
Yes.
Representative Land.
So is there any objection to putting this on consent?
Okay, great.
Thank you.
So 1530 is a real important bill, and I appreciate everybody coming through and working on this This is what it's all about and I want to thank represent Ford for heading up that subcommittee I'm gonna take about five minutes all this stuff was just brought in and dumped in front of us by Jen, and I want to get it organized a little bit before I move forward.
I don't even know where my paperwork is now.
So let's take a five-minute break here.
If somebody has to go to the washroom or something, go ahead.
We'll come back in a few moments.
Okay, what do we got here?
Thank you.
Okay, I'd like to go ahead with the executive sessions we have set up for today.
As a reminder to folks, we had 103 bills.
We have already acted upon at a prior session about a third of those.
And right now, Lindsay is working, our administrative assistant is working on getting the reports done for about 40 of those.
And so, you know, when the 30 and 40, that leaves another 30-some-odd that we've got to do today and tomorrow.
Thank you.
getting the reports done for about 40 of those.
And so, you know, when the 30 and 40, that leaves another 30-some-odd that we've got to do today and tomorrow if it's necessary.
And it kind of looks to me like it's going to be necessary.
So the first bill which we'd like to have is HB 1047, relative to the Charter Public School Joint Legislative Oversight Committee Now I I'm seeing that There is an amendment floating around here on that one.
Is that correct?
That is correct.
I have an amendment Amendment, okay, what we're going to be doing with amendments will allow discussion, but we're not going to take a motion on the amendment Okay So so you have an amendment amendment.
Yes, I do.
I have an amendment.
It's number 0652H.
And it simply is an amendment that actually Representative Ladd, you suggested.
And that is that changing the number of Senate representatives on the oversight committee.
So the committee shall include the chairperson of the House or designee the chairperson of the Senate committee or designee the chairperson of the House finance or designee one representative appointed by the Speaker of the House and one senator appointed by the President.
In the initial bill, I I had some outside people in and you suggested to take them out so that they could come in as witnesses or experts or give testimony but to not put them on the committee.
So this is meeting your your suggestion.
So thank you.
I'm trying to find the amendment.
Okay.
You need a couple, Bill?
There's more here.
Okay.
Okay, just open for discussion.
Is there any further discussion on this amendment?
It appears to me that the amendment primarily whittles down the Senate members on this.
Am I correct?
It also takes out, you suggested to take out the non-voting member from the Department of Education.
and that was you know so that we had talked about they could come for testimony and that sort of thing, but to not have them part of the committee itself.
Okay, I'm going to get...
Mr.
Chair.
Yes, go ahead.
So are those, the members that you you took out are those currently members of the The Charter public school oversight committee So How does the how does the membership now under the proposed amendment differ from the current membership of the Charter?
Public school oversight committee proposed amendment differ from the current membership of the Charter Public School Oversight Committee?
So, this amendment, basically, it, you know, speaks to paragraph two, and it remains the same, except for taking out the non-voting member representative from the Department of Education.
And as I said, that was one of the things that Chairman Ladd had suggested as a change in this particular bill.
But other than that, it doesn't change it.
So just to be clear, though, my question isn't to how it compares with the bill, but how does it compare to the current membership?
Because there is a current charter public school oversight.
There is.
Yes, there is.
And it doesn't change the makeup of the committee as such.
Okay.
Thanks.
The major change was this non-voting member.
Okay.
Yes.
I think the membership, doesn't this, I'm sorry.
Thank you.
Doesn't the amended bill add House Finance Committee Chair?
Yeah, I think it, yes, it had, I'm sorry, yes, it did, it had the House Finance and that's removed also on suggestion.
So that we're back down.
This amendment puts it back down to just senators and representatives.
I thought, though, that the current committee does not mandate the finance chair or designee.
It's taken out in the amendment.
Okay.
No, it doesn't?
It's been so long since I've been in this.
Senate, the House, the Senate.
Oh, the chairperson.
Yes, I see that now.
Yep.
But it's got one senator as opposed to.
One representative appointed by the senator and one Senate.
Still has two Senators.
Yes.
The chairperson.
Yeah.
Yes.
Okay.
Is there any further discussion on the amendment?
That's where we're going.
So just an informal show of hands here.
Is there anybody here that's not supporting the amendment?
But we have to, yeah, and okay, I think we're just going to roll ahead with a motion.
And I'm going to ask on this particular one that Representative Boehm provide a motion, please.
And I move ITL on 1047.
On the amendment?
No, we've had the discussion on the amendment.
Okay.
Now we're just moving forward on the bill.
I'll second that motion.
Representative Bohm, would you please speak to your motion?
Yes, thank you.
I believe we have another bill, HB 1236, which will cover the same thing.
So, I don't think this bill is necessary.
Representative Cordelli.
Thank you.
My concern is Section 2 at the end of the page in the bill 25 to 29 lines.
And this basically requires an annual report by the State Board of Education on recommendations for charter schools where it is not a mandated annual report currently.
So I think this is really just creating busy work for the State Board.
Further discussion?
Representative Tanner.
Yes, and I'm sorry, I was kind of confused with this whole thing, but the original statute has three senators, and I've reduced it to two.
I just want to point out to the committee that the last time this committee met, the legislative oversight for charters, was in 2016.
That was the last time they met, because, number one, they couldn't get a quorum, and evidently they didn't think it was necessary to meet, that they didn't have enough information or whatever to go over.
The last report that they ever issued was in 2011.
And, you know, since 2011, you think of the change that we've had in charter schools and the influx of federal money, actually, as startup money for new charter schools.
I think this is an area where we need to have legislative oversight and we needed to streamline the committee, which I did, and also set a statute that says that they had to file a report.
And if there's nothing to be reported, all they have to do is say a report is nothing to be reported.
But obviously, they didn't do that since 2011.
So that's why that was the impetus for this bill and I certainly think it needs a lot more oversight that the charter schools need a lot more oversight at this point and that I would offer that we vote against this bill and have an ought to pass bill with the amendment.
Thank you.
Any further discussion?
Yes, Representative Luno.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
So while the committee is called, and it's an existing committee, I think that's important to know.
It's an existing committee with three senators on it the bill with the amendment would streamline that possibly the word oversight committee which is the current name of the committee i don't know if oversight is really a great name for it but just the fact that they they would issue an annual report because of the bill, because of Bill 1047 as amended, I think is tremendous.
Because one of the things that I think we've heard on and on is that charters provide the opportunity for innovation.
And I don't understand how the state would actually capture those innovative measures without having an annual report on what that is.
I think this is a tremendous opportunity to collect information that could be used in our other public schools.
And if for whatever reasons the current committee has a difficult time meeting because of its membership composition, then I think this is an opportunity to change that and provide the state with the information that I think all of our public education, all of our students, all 160,000 students across the state could benefit from.
So I would urge not going with the ITL motion.
The other bill that Representative Boehm mentioned, 1236, I think, is a state accountability commission for reviewing the accountability standards for our school districts.
So it is not the same as what this would do.
And like I say, the commission, the committee already exists.
And this bill I think substantially improves the membership of the committee and the ability for that committee to produce reports that would be beneficial to all of our public schools.
Is there any further discussion, Representative Porter?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Having served as chair or on several commissions and committees in my time in the legislature, it's not unusual to require an annual report.
In fact, most of them do.
So the legislature knows what's going on in that committee or commission and in that section of life that the committee or commission is overseeing.
So I don't see that having to produce a report should be a reason why we should eliminate this bill.
Thank you.
Further discussion?
Mr.
Clerk, would you please call the roll?
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
We are voting on 1047, and it is ITL.
Representative Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Lange.
Representative Boehm.
Yes.
Representative Lekas.
Representative Lascellas.
Did I say it right?
Yes.
Representative Hobson.
Representative Ford.
Yes.
Representative Soda.
Representative Ford.
Yes.
Representative Sotay.
Representative Nelson.
Yes.
Representative Luno.
No.
Representative Walsh.
I'm sorry.
Walner.
No.
Representative Representative Cornell?
Representative Tanner?
No.
Representative Ellison?
Representative Cornell.
No.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Ellison.
No.
Representative Mullen.
Representative Mary.
No.
Representative Porter.
Representative Hall you leave today so you know majority and minority, I need to have them.
Our administrative assistant needs to get on this as quickly as possible.
So please get them done today, even if it's a two or three-liner.
Get them done, please.
Okay, the next bill is HB 1051 this bill is relative to see to the State Board of Education rules for credits for alternative extended learning and work based programs I hand the gavel over to represent Cordelli thank you you, Mr.
Chair.
And I'll call on the chairman for a motion.
I'd like to move ITL.
Thank you.
Is there a second?
I second.
Representative Lakers, thank you.
Discussion by the chairman?
Yes, some brief discussion here.
I believe that this bill would allow local boards authority to reject credit earned through approved alternative education programs such as learn everywhere program and where it says in the bill on line six the programs which may be accepted by the local school board these these learn everywhere program credits are approved by the State Board of Education based upon the competencies offered in that course and approved by the State Board as the State Board does set academic standards so in conclusion I feel that it provides it will eliminate some of the opportunity we have for the choice of programs taking a program through learn everywhere program you could be out of sequence in your own high school and taking courses you can go to learn everywhere program and get that course or get something equivalent to it so I recommend ITO thank you resident like us any comments you know comments from the committee represented Tanner yes you, Mr.
Chair.
The bill was pretty simple, and actually the Department of Education has started to set up on their website vetting and recommending different programs for their Learn Everywhere program.
After the sentence that Chairman Ladd read, there's also one that says nothing in this subparagraph shall prevent us local school district from approving vendors offering credit for the alternative extended learning or work based programs which do not appear on the pre-approved list maintained by the state this was a bill the intent of this this bill from me was to allow for a spot at the Department of Education where people, parents who wanted their child to do a Learn Everywhere program or an alternative program or workplace program could go to a site on DOE and find groups that were vetted by DOE that they actually had an application to them, they vetted them, and they approved them.
And certainly we've talked about criminal background checks and a few other things that are kind of key in consumer.
when a consumer is looking for a product, and it's particularly an education product where they are sending their child to.
I think the bill was very simple, and I think it's very needed, and I would urge people to vote against the ITL.
Thank you.
Further discussion?
Representative Lakers and then Representative Luno.
Yeah, my understanding is that second part, like you said, is they did a lot of work to put it all out there so that it's available for parents to find.
But my objection is still the same as was presented by Rep.
Ladd is the word may.
Representative Luno.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
So I think this is sort of a question of the chair.
Obviously, the Learn Everywhere program is relatively new.
Rules came out recently, and I think the list of education service providers has has started to come out and but but given how the the current statute reads and what representative Tanner is trying to accomplish in 1051 under the under under the current law uh mr chair do um do districts have the and i guess beyond the state minimum standards the districts have to accept all learn everywhere credits and apply them towards graduation as we heard from the department and when testified on the bill, that they have matched up these Learn Everywhere courses or programs with competencies, and that those competencies are associated with various courses required for graduation credit.
So what the bill is stating that although the State Board of Education has authority to do so pursuant to the rulemaking process 541-8 there the bill is looking at saying no the school board can reject that particular learn everywhere program that's would be seen by the State Board as meeting those competencies and approved by the State Board but the local board would not have to approve and so the student would therefore I have to take the course again or take some other form some other you know course to acquire that credit so I think there's a lot to this bill I have stated that I think the part of this bill which really is I object to is on line six where the word may is used and it doesn't say shall as is as done and accepted in rulemaking already so so So just a follow up on that Rick, because I'm not sure that, so as an example, the state minimum standards do not require world language for graduation, correct?
Correct.
So a high school could require, let's say, a year of world language as part of their graduation requirements, correct?
A high school could do that.
And would a high school have to accept a Learn Everywhere credit to meet the world language requirement, even if that Learn Everywhere credit did not include any of the competencies for world language?
If the high school has gone above the minimum, then you would receive credit for that course in the Learn Everywhere, but it doesn't necessarily say you are going to be offering a credit that parallels with what the school districts looking at so you know I think what we're trying to do is say that by the district or the state board approving a course, if it matches the credits offered or demanded for that course, which the local school district has put in place, then it would count towards graduation.
I think, you know, that's what...
No, that answers it.
So the local board is still the one that sets the graduation requirements for that school district.
Well, we have that in the minimum standards for public school approval.
However, if, in fact, they have this as one of the requirements for their graduation from school district X and the student achieves those competencies through a program offered by through the learn everywhere or you know or maybe in another school that would count towards the graduation credit as long as it's consistent with the local graduation requirements great thank you represent Porter isn't it in still in current law or have we taken it out that the local school board is the one that determines our graduation requirements for their students and sets the standards for them I always understood as a school board member that I am responsible for making sure that all the children who graduate from my school district have met the competencies and requirements that we the local board have set up to to grant the diploma from my high school is that still the law academic standards are set by the state that's not the question that I asked you is it not the responsibility to me of the local school board to set the standards for the local graduation requirements to grant a local diploma from a local high school?
Isn't that their responsibility in law?
You're coming from a different focus here.
If, in fact, and as I just discussed with Representative Luno, if a student took a course which matches and meets the competencies of the course that's required for graduation set by the local school district then the student is should be given approval for that course it's not the local local authorities have no control of it's all about competencies it's not about seat time but it's still under law that local control by local school boards is what determines the graduation requirements for the local high school is that accurate the local school board will set graduation requirements and courses or requirements and we oftentimes used course or program and when in fact we're really looking at competencies my point being that requiring local school boards to accept something that they have not approved seems contradictory to me from their local control that they have over the content that they're responsible for providing a school district's responsible especially a high school to submit 43 courses for approval for the minimum public school standards with those 43 submitted courses there are also associated competencies if in fact the state recognizes that the there are also associated competencies.
If, in fact, the state recognizes that the student has mastered those competencies via another avenue, then the student should get credit for that requirement at the local level.
So you are telling me that it is not the local board that has responsibility for acknowledging that those competencies have been met.
It is the board sets the competencies for their course, but if that is accomplished via some other Learning Everywhere activity, then they should get credit for those competencies.
Thank you.
I'm just going to chime in even on the sub, but some of you know I'm also the squadron commander for our legislative Civil Air Patrol squadron.
And I am actually in the middle of doing this process for the Civil Air Patrol's aerospace education program.
And if anybody thinks it's an easy way to get a kid a credit, they have no idea the ridiculous amount of paperwork I have to submit to DOE to try to get this program approved.
So I think they already have a significant and robust vetting process in doing this.
And I guess I see this bill as redundant.
And as it served on JALCAR, I also saw those rules.
So again, I think it's covered.
And ITL is the appropriate recommendation Further discussion on the bill not seeing any Mr.
Clerk would you please call the roll?
Yes, Mr.
Chairman.
Representative Cordelli, the motion is ITL and it's bill number 1051.
Representative Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Lang.
Representative Boehm.
Yes.
Representative Lekas.
Representative Vassellis.
Yes.
Representative Hobson.
Representative Ford.
Yes.
Representative Sodai.
Representative Nelson.
Yes.
Representative Luna.
No.
and forward yes representative so die yes representative nelson yes representative luna no okay representative walner no representative cornell no representative tanner no representative ellison no representative mullen no representative murray no representative porter no Ah, did I miss somebody?
Representative Mullen.
No.
Representative Murray.
Representative Porter.
No.
Ah, did I miss somebody here, right?
Representative Porter, Representative Hall.
Okay, all right.
Representative Ladd.
Yes.
Okay.
10-9.
Okay, so again, Representative Tanner.
Okay, the next bill, which we have on our plate here, is HB 1114.
This bill is relative to education service providers under the Education Freedom Account Program.
Do we have any amendments being proposed on this one?
Yes, we do.
Okay.
We have amendments.
So we will open up the discussion with no motions made on the discussion during the separate.
Okay, let's see.
11-14.
Okay.
This stack here.
Where did you put all of the, they, all they got mixed up in this other stack.
Okay.
Sure.
Representative Tanner, what, is it your, or Representative Cornell, is it yours?
Yeah.
Why don't you go ahead, Patty, and start explaining, I'll find it.
All right.
Pardon me?
Oh, I know.
I'm just hunting through.
The amendment actually just removes lines 7 through 19 of the original bill and just states that the scholarship organization shall comply in a directory of public profiles for each education service provider listed.
And the intent of this was to make the information easy and convenient for parents to find when they're looking for a provider for their student that they want to go somewhere other than the local public school so the intent of this was to make it easier for parents.
On line six, where do you end that sentence?
That includes.
After the word listed.
Okay.
And then everything A through J is eliminated?
Yes.
The effective date remains the same and I believe this information is already available so should be easy for them to just put it into a list that parents can just look at the represent lakers yes not only is this already done when they did rules they added to the original stuff and and added particular things that had to be done by the vendors and said that it had to go on the DOE website it is already on on the DOE website.
It already has a bunch more information than was in the original, and it's done.
It's there.
You can find it.
Further discussion?
You know, on the discussion here.
So my question to everybody is that if it's already being done, and we assume that it is, then what does this really make any difference one way or the other?
Or by doing it, do we just enforce the idea that the directory profiles of the providers will just be listed on listed.
Mr.
Chair?
Yeah.
Yes, by putting this in law, it would assure that it would continue to be done.
It strengthens the program.
So it is being done right now.
Okay.
Education site, so it's covered in both places.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
It just seems like it would be a good way to assure that the program that you all want to succeed so much.
We want to see?
You all want to see succeed so much that it would protect that program by having a piece of legislation that requires this to happen, because rules can be changed.
But if it's in the RSA's it's harder to do is there further discussion on the discussion okay I'm going to take about a five-minute caucus okay Okay.
What was the bill and amendment number?
It's 1114.
Bill number?
1114?
Yeah, this one right here.
And amendment number?
Let's see, I don't have to.
Yeah.
I don't have to.
Dave, do you have any more of those?
I didn't have the amendment.
I'm looking for it.
I just can't find it.
Okay, good.
I have a show.
Thank you.
Make sure all the mics are off.
Move ITL.
Thank you.
I think as we discussed briefly before the motion, I don't think that this bill is needed.
It's already being done.
It's in rules.
So I don't see any need for the bill.
Nothing to add.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I'm trying to find the list on the sites, and I'm really having a difficult time.
So I'm really concerned that we say this is up here, but when I went to the Department of Education, I couldn't find it.
When I went to the scholarship fund page, I couldn't find it.
Now I'm on New Hampshire Education Freedom Accounts, and there is a parent handbook, but it's not listed on the Department of Education site.
A list of schools is.
So just so you know, I've been working for the last 10 minutes trying to find it thanks very much mr.
chair yeah I think I telling this speaks volumes about what the what the real purpose behind quote education freedom accounts otherwise known as voucher programs in other states.
The New Hampshire ZFA is more expensive than any voucher program in any state of the union and provides opportunities for parents or for families to collect money from the state to be used to pay private school tuition or homeschooling costs or who knows what else because of the lack of accountability in the program.
At least this bill would have provided families with a directory of educational service providers that could be useful for helping to educate their children.
But given the fact that apparently the legislature is not interested in doing that, I really do think it confirms most Granite Staters' suspicion about how their tax money is being stolen to be used for this program.
Thank you.
I would just take exception to the comment that money is being stolen.
Mr.
Chair?
Sorry again.
So we just approved these rules in Jalcar no more than, I think, two, three weeks ago after an extensive debate.
And this list is being compiled regularly.
I understand this is a brand new law.
So whether Representative Porter can find the list or not, just understand they're still establishing, evaluating, and creating that list, especially everything that fell under Section O, which was other things the legislature can't think of section that allows for the expenditure of those funds.
So, again, I think they are doing it.
The testimony in the JALCAR committee was that both from the scholarship fund and from Commissioner Edelbluth was these things are being done.
They're establishing the list, and they'll be up.
As they approve more and more organizations or more and more opportunities to use EFA funds they will add to that list but understand it is they literally just have the rules approved three weeks ago thank you mr.
chair I did but we've been told they're up already and we've been told that they've been up already for the last two weeks And the list is there.
It's easy for people to find Who provides the services?
It's easy to know what services they provide because it's in rules and it's up online and Right now I'm not finding it.
And I think that, for me, makes passing HB 114 more important because it needs to be there so parents can make informed decisions about how they're going to spend the money that they are getting for their children's education.
If you the program to be successful I would think you would want to make sure that that kind of information was readily available representative Mullen thank you mr.
chair I have seen the list but that's exactly what it is.
It's a list of programs.
It does not include profile information about the programs.
So there are schools and tutoring agencies and things like that, the names of the organizations on the list, but there's nothing about what kinds of programs.
And I just want to draw attention to the fact that when this bill was originally presented to the committee, it was presented by me.
And the complaint at that time, because Representative Cornell had asked me to present her bill in her absence, at the time, the concern from the committee was that the information that was being asked for was not necessarily appropriate to every single education service provider when I look at this list I don't see any individuals on the list so I guess my question to representative Lang would be are there rules that allow for the collection of information on individuals who are functioning as educational service providers, as opposed to just the name of a school or the name of Brave Writer or Timber Doodle Company.
I mean, there are names here, but there's no information about them.
So my concern is that these are not profiles.
Thank you.
Representative Cordelli and then Representative Lekas.
Representative Lange discussed the rules that were recently passed, and the rules include the requirement for the scholarship organization to include not just the name, but the eligible services provided, the fee amounts received for services, and the number of EFA students received.
Those are all in rules that were recently passed represent lekkas yes originally what had intended to be done before the rules were passed was there was a person who was going to set up a website specifically so that all this stuff could to be on there but then in rules they said no it had to be on the DOE website and so the names are there and and that was just last Monday and the scholarship organization has been working at getting all that together and I believe the intent is there's even going to be direct links to each of these organizations once it's completed but that was last Monday so they've had to change what they were going to do to what they are going to do now and they're scrambling to do do that.
But my understanding is they are, at this moment, entering that information.
Can I just answer, Representative Lakers, I do not for a second doubt the fact that an attempt is being made to gather information and get it up and running.
My concern is that if we do not put this into statute ten years from now how are we going to be you know God well and everybody will be retired by then right that's involved with this process right now and how are we going to guarantee moving forward that the process remains mandatory and and that's that's why we put things into statute.
So thank you.
By then I hope to be in the Bahamas growing oranges.
Okay.
Any further discussion on the committee's part?
Yes, Representative Hall.
I'm just going to say 15 minutes ago I heard this was was all up, everything's there, and now we find out it's not there, well then it's going to be there.
And I think that that's difficult when you're making decisions.
I'm basing it on what I'm hearing.
I'm new to the committee and I hear something and then I say, well, maybe not.
So, I just want to say that.
Thank you.
Representative Luno?
No, thanks very much, Mr.
Chair mr chair and and thank you representative hall for pointing that out because i think we all have a responsibility to uh to not be deceptive and not to lie in front of the to other members of the committee nor to people across the granite state so when you say something like it's already up but fail to recognize as representative Representative Mullen pointed out, that the actionable thing that this brings is the word profiles, not just the names of these service providers.
So, you know, I would just caution members of the committee to make sure you read the bill and understand what the bill is intended to do before bringing that information before the committee and to our constituents.
Thank you.
Representative Cordelli.
I would just point out that the law requires that a parent advisory committee be formed.
And I think that they're starting to look at that in the scholarship organization.
And I think that that parent advisory committee will be perfectly capable of making recommendations on what information should be available to parents in addition to what is required in rules.
Further discussion?
Yes, Representative Lucas.
I'm sorry.
I was looking at the other part.
Yes, the list was there.
In fact, we just looked it up here.
The profiles are being put up.
And I was referring to the fact that there is a list there.
They are improving that list as time goes on.
But the list is there.
I was not saying everything is completely done.
How can it be be in one week so I wasn't trying to lie or give misinformation I was simply trying to say that list is up there we found it here there's just a link and it says providers and you click on it and it comes right up it's very easy to see it's there they are entering the information to add more information to that but the list is there and has been it was here there last week.
Thank you Any further discussion?
Mr.
Clark would you please call the roll?
All represent Porter.
Thank you, mr.
Chair, and this is this is not a Angry debate.
It's just to let you know I learned something this morning that there's two different places that you might look that the education scholarship children's scholarship fund is not the same as the children's scholarship fund for EFA's and then in order to if you look children's scholarship fund in New Hampshire you're looking up the tax credit program but if you look up of Children's Scholarship Fund in New Hampshire, you're looking up the tax credit program.
But if you look up Children's Scholarship Fund under Education Freedom Accounts, you're looking at Education Freedom Accounts.
So a parent would need to know the difference between those two elements of the scholarship-granting organization.
I looked up Children's Scholars's scholarship fund which I understood to be the name of the scholarship granting organization that works with EFA but evidently it's a different one or it has a different name or it's under somehow different because the information is different when you look at the two sites.
Thank you.
Thank you for your point of clarification.
Further discussion?
None?
Mr.
Clerk?
I'll make sure I have this right.
It's amendment 0816?
No.
This is straight.
Street.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
Yes.acellas.
Representative Hopson.
Yes.
Representative Ford.
Representative Sody.
Yes.
Representative Nelson.
Representative Luna.
No.
Representative Cornell.
Representative Woolner.
No.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Ellison.
No.
Representative Mullen.
Representative Mary.
No.
Representative Porter.
Representative Paul.
No.
Representative Ladd.
Yes.
Okay, uh, some have up is 1131.
This is a bill relative to facial covering policies for schools.
1131.
Do we have amendments out on this one?
I believe so.
Search through your paperwork.
1131.
Do you have one on 1131, Bill?
No?
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
That's it.
Here it is.
It's just coming around.
Okay.
Someone to look.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll recognize Representative Cordelli for a motion.
Yes, I would like to move out to pass and offer amendment 0896.
You need a second on the out to pass.
Yeah, sorry.
Representative Bowen.
Okay.
Representative Cordelli, do you want to speak to your motion of ought to pass?
Yes, thank you.
We recently had a joint announcement by the governor, the Department of Health, the Department of Education no longer recommending universal face masking in the state, and that included for schools.
I think that, excuse me, I think for too long, schools have been driven by things other than educational considerations when it comes to face masks.
And I think now with this bill, I think we should move forward with eliminating face mask policies in schools.
Do you want to offer...
forward with eliminating face mask policies in schools yes the amendment is zero eight nine six yeah I'm yes, ought to pass on the amendment.
So we have a motion on the floor to OTP for the bill, but we have the amendment of 0896H as an amended amendment to that bill.
Would you like to speak to that, Representative Cordelli?
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
This amendment is actually very simple.
It does two things.
One, it removes from the original bill that non-public schools are included in the legislation.
This will apply to public schools and public academies only.
And the second thing it does is on line 25, it changes the effective date to upon passage.
Okay.
Is there...
We never got a second on the amendment, did we?
Representative Saude?
So, okay.
So we got a second on it, and you've already given your discussion.
Sorry for the miscue here.
A further discussion?
Yes, Representative Mullen.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
I believe it also removes the superintendent of schools as a determining factor in, if you look at line four of the original bill, the school board of a school district, the superintendent or chief administrative officer of a school district, and authorities, yada, yada, yada.
if you look at the amended bill it says the school board of a school district or the chief executive officer of a chartered public school I was wondering if representative Cordelli could speak to why the superintendent seems to have disappeared thank you the question it's really the school board that adopts policies not the superintendent who adopts policy so we're talking about policies here so I thought it was appropriate that it's specifies the school board since that's their responsibility would that not be the same for the charters or the, I mean, you've given the authority to the executive officer of a chartered public school.
They have a board of trustees, but I don't think that the board of trustees would necessarily get involved with policies at the charter school.
Follow up to that?
Do we know that that's the case?
Do we not think that the board of trustees is responsible for the development of policies at their charter school?
And Representative Cordelli, I'll open that question up to anybody that can answer it, not just you.
The representative from Bedford's opened up a question for all of us.
There you go.
Is the Board of Trustees on a  I mean, it has been our practice to sort of acknowledge that Board of Trustees in a similar way, if not identical, to the school board of the public school at large.
So I guess I'm confused as to why the executive officer would be left in, the superintendent would be taken out, and the board of trustees appears nowhere.
Representative Luna?
So thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And Representative Mullen's point, I think, is very clear that boards are responsible for policy and they're responsible for enforcement through their selection as a chief executive officer, whether that's the superintendent of the school district or the the ceo of of another organization that's just governance structure and um and i i think this um you know this is an indication that um that that uh 11 31 is just not ready for prime time because it has basically a conflicting charge that's different for public schools or school districts than it is for other public schools.
And furthermore, it is completely quiet on any consideration for a non-public school that may be under contract with a school district to provide educational services.
Further discussion?
Representative Porter?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
if in the future when COVID is gone if another viral deadly viral infection comes forward and it is known without a doubt that wearing a mask protects people from that deadly disease will this passing this amendment prevent all All our public schools from requiring people to wear masks but not private schools just public schools I should mean I think that's covered on lines seven and eight six seven and eight shall not adopt to enforce enforce implement a policy that requires students remembers the public to wear a facial covering.
And operative words they are not require.
So it's a student parental option.
Representative Hull.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Could someone explain to me why non-public schools are not held to this account?
I'm not really sure I understand that.
I think our responsibility primarily is for the public schools.
I did not think that delving into policies for non-public schools was appropriate here.
And I think that during the pandemic, we saw that many non-public schools remained open while public schools were closed and also provided optional masking rather than mandatory masking.
Representative Boone.
Thank you.
In response to a couple of questions.
Number one, the superintendent worked for the school board, so that's really not an issue.
And for the board of trustees, they don't really read that often to run things.
Also, for the school boards, cannot require, if there's a further epidemic of some kind, the state can require, just like the government in an emergency thing.
One of the problems we have now is the governor says it's not needed anymore.
Yes, there are some schools saying we're still requiring it.
No, that should not be the school's responsibility.
That's the government's responsibility.
And by having some schools requiring it and some schools not, it just makes more people saying why are they doing it why aren't we doing it and just causes all kinds of confusion so I think it's it's the government's responsibility the state can do an emergency thing saying that's what it is but let's not give authority to a school board that really should not have that authority.
Thank you.
I have a question, and I think everybody knows I'm a person that believes in choice on this topic.
I'm looking at this bill in terms of the amendment on line 17 and the original bill on line 1617.
and I'm going to read it and I'm going to ask for somebody to please explain to me because I do not like passing anything which I cannot give a definition for terminology any person claiming to be aggrieved by a violation of this section including the attorney general may initiate a civil action against the school school district school board or other public entity in superior court other public entity are we now the title of this bill deals with schools now are we now taking this a whole huge step beyond the public schools?
That's my question.
I'm asking out there other entity public entity Question Other words if we're going to address schools perhaps we need to get other public entity out of it yes I must apologize that I wasn't here for the hearing on this but I'm also confused by that last paragraph because if if a person feels aggrieved by a violation of this section, it sounds like they can go to the attorney general and do civil action.
But then section three says a violation of this section by an educator, and the educator is an employee of the school and filling out the policy of the school, how are they liable under this law?
And I don't understand why it even has anything to do with the code of conduct because they're employees.
They're doing a job that the school board and the superintendent who works for the school board and the governor who sets things and, you know, Dr.
Chan who comes out with the latest deal.
I don't  that whole section seems like it's just  shouldn't belong there.
I mean, I just don't understand it.
So maybe when we're talking about any entity, we might also talk about why are educators singled out in this?
Why, you know, should, if the cafeteria lady says to the person next to her that's working there, you have to wear a face mask, is she you know they have to wear gloves and they have to wear a face mask.
Is she, you know, and they have to wear gloves and they have to keep their hair out of the food.
If anybody is individually listed, it should be somebody like that or the janitor that has people working for him that he says to the janitor, to the people working, employees, that they have to have proper covering for, you know, doing spraying for mosquitoes or whatever around the school.
So I just find that last paragraph really offensive to me as a former educator, I guess.
Representative Ford?
Use your mic.
I'm wondering if that might include things like collective bargaining units so that that as a unit might raise an objection or call for some action to be taken by way of being representatives of groups of employees.
No, it doesn't preclude it, though.
It's a union.
It says an educator.
Any person?
Representative Allison.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
This bill and the amendment make no sense from a public health perspective, none at all.
And in terms of schools who had varying policies about mask mandates, in most cases there were schools where there were surges or classes where there were surges, and it made sense to have a different policy in that school from another school.
So I strongly object to the bill and I would build on what Representative Porter said, that in the future, we don't know what this looks like.
And to tie the hands of these institutions is unconscionable, actually.
Thank you.
Further discussion?
Representative Lekas and then I think Representative Luna.
As we all heard from the professional who deals with risk management and risk amelioration, masks do not have any effect against viruses, and we're talking about a virus.
said if you wear a respirator it has a very tiny effect that there are much more effective things that schools could do and could have used the ESSER money for including what we do here with the machines that actually kill the virus and so forcing children to and he also said the respirators could not be fitted for children age 12 and under and so forcing children to wear a mask for to no purpose whatsoever since it has no effect against viruses if it was was bacteria, that would be a different matter.
But viruses are so small, he said it makes no difference because you cannot seal them well enough, and they just come in the sides, the top, whatever.
And therefore, he said, you know, it makes no sense to have a law that does something ineffective that harms children.
Thank you.
It makes no sense to have a law that does something ineffective that harms children.
Representative Luna?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So, you know, notwithstanding my earlier comments with regards to the truthfulness of information presented to this committee, Obviously, we hear from various interested parties with different levels of information that may or may not correspond with science, but that's what we do when we listen to testimony from people that present to the committee.
So I think from some of that you really need to take it with a grain of salt because we've obviously heard testimony in the other direction Thank you.
So, so I think from some of that, you really need to take it with a grain of salt because we've obviously heard testimony to the other in the other direction to to support the use of of masks as a as a sound mitigation approach to to slowing down transmission of of of a contagion.
So, you know, I think another thing that's very relevant when looking at 1131, in particular, if we're seeing this as, well, this basically prevents it from being decided at a local level, but instead should be determined by a statewide public health, is that we actually heard from the governor specifically that the public health needs can vary significantly at the local level, maybe by county, maybe by city, maybe by town.
And obviously, the state is in a position to understand all of those differences the way the leadership, school district leadership, school district governance is at the local level.
So I think this actually removes one of the tools that the governor found so important during the management of the COVID pandemic.
So thank you and I hope we'll see fit to ITL this bill.
Representative Porter.
Thank you Mr.
Chair.
If I were a parent of a child that was medically fragile, and that child got COVID and died because there was no mask mandate in their school, what would be my legal rights under this bill?
Thank you.
I'm not sure I understood the question but basically it's a parental option under the spill so that parent would be able to mask their child if they saw fit they could mask their own child but the kid next to him who's got COVID and sneezes at him and gives him COVID doesn't have to have a mask on.
I'm just wondering what would be the recourse for that parent.
I think that children are in school from approximately 7.30 to 2.30 during the day, those hours children are in school from approximately 7 30 to 2 30 during the day those hours children are outside of school for the majority of time i think trying to identify where someone caught covid might be a difficult task i don't see that as a valid argument against the bill.
Representative Cornell.
I may have missed it, but did we get an answer to the definition of the person claiming to be aggrieved by a violation of the sectional, what that aggrieved meant?
I may have missed it, but wasn't that your question, Chairman, about the...
My question was relative to what is the definition of other public entity.
I still haven't had an answer to that yet.
I do have some other concerns with where we're going.
we had a bill earlier which we dealt with, HB 1336, which dealt with the Code of Ethics, and we, by unanimous consent here on this particular committee, decided to write an administrative letter to the Department of Education stating that we opine that the modifications to the code can best be accomplished through the rulemaking process.
Now, here we are again going down a similar type road.
I have some concern with that, and maybe I'm interpreting it incorrectly.
I'm one that's all for masks should be totally optional.
And I agree in the science that we had presented to us.
However, how we're approaching it here gives me some real concerns.
I don't know what entity means and this is what got us into trouble with another bill earlier quite a while ago and and when we're talking about discrimination and and then we have this other that we just finished in 1336 so those are two concerns i'm going to have to have answered yes i i didn't get an answer either about why if the school board and the school district or the chief executive officer of the charter school makes these decisions and implements them, why on earth is Section 3 about an educator?
I mean, I don't even, I don't understand that at all, why an educator is liable under this section, why it's even listed under this section, because they have nothing, you know, the teacher, if they're requiring masks or doing it, fulfilling their job and can be fired for, you know, not doing their job.
And then you're saying that if they do their job Thank you.
master doing it, fulfilling their job, and can be fired for, you know, not doing their job.
And then you're saying that if they do their job and the public entity sues them, then they can lose their job anyway by certification through the code of ethics.
I just don't understand how that whole section is even there.
That's, the public entity bothers me too because that that is like the whole world I mean it was anybody and then the other thing is that section three I don't know if it's the fuddling to anybody besides me if we have to represent you laying I can give one answer to representative Mullen's question about the Board of Trustees versus the chief executive.
Under RSA 194-5, 194-B, colon 5, charter public schools authority and duties of the Board of Trustees, policy is not listed.
They're actually a financial board for the most part dealing with contracts and dealing with you know money issues and receiving donations real estate that kind of thing so the chief executive officer of would be responsible for the policy and dictates represent Cordelli thank you I see section three.
If a teacher within a school required their students to wear a mask, I think that's where this section three might come in.
come in and in terms of, entity enrollment number 2 a person claiming to be aggrieved in violation of this section and this section relates to schools charter schools can be chartered via the several means one a public school can form a charter school community college a group of parents a foundation can form a charter school according to our law so I think that maybe they would meet the criteria for other entities.
Representative Mullen.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So let me run something by you and see whether or not I'm considering this in the right light.
if I'm a classroom teacher and I have a student in my class that is allergic to peanuts or tree nuts or ground nuts or any nuts and I confab with the counselor, the administration or whatever and we decide that we're going to send home a note to parents that says, in this, I thought that was us.
I'm like, okay, eat the nuts.
And I send home, it's agreed that I'm going to have a nut-free classroom.
This happens.
It's happened in my life that I have been that school counselor that has coordinated the writing and dissemination of the letter that says in this particular classroom, because of the severity of this child's illness or allergy, it's nut-free.
So now we're in 2022, and we've got a kid who's immunocompromised in a classroom, and it's cold and flu season, or they're a cancer patient and they're undergoing chemo.
If we put...
What are we we do are we contemplating putting a law into effect that says that the school does not have the authority in that situation to require masks in that classroom and if so if they can bring they can start litigation and receive just reward or whatever.
Are we going to be doing that for granola bars that have peanuts in it or perfumes that students are allergic?
Where does this end?
It would seem to me that this is a philosophy.
and whether or not you agree that everything should be optional or everything should be mandated, in the end it's going to come down to the individuals in that classroom or in that school.
How do we not make this into a litiginous situation?
Go ahead.
I think we're talking about facial coverings, not nuts, in regard to this.
I don't see where the nut argument comes in, but certainly if there were students who were compromised, the parents can say that they want them to be masked.
And certainly, we've seen classrooms, when classrooms reopened after being closed, they had spacing between children as a preventative measure.
Some had plexiglass Partitions I see I see all kinds of options to protecting an immune immunity compromised individual student within that classroom Without the need to mandate that every child in that class be masked.
The parents in the classroom, other parents could certainly choose to cover their, have their students face covered if they so chose.
But no, we can't lose sight of the fact also about the educational impact that the mask mandates have had.
You know, young children with facial recognition, all sorts of studies about the impact of facial masks during this period.
And the educational impact was really left out of the equation, in my opinion.
With all due respect, Representative Cordelli, I don't think they're two separate issues.
I think that if you're requiring a student to wear a mask in a classroom and requiring a student not to bring peanuts in their lunch bag, you're still requiring them to do something that they might otherwise have wanted or not wanted to do.
And I would caution everybody at thinking about what we're doing and what kind of a can of worms this is going to open up.
I pledge not to offer any legislation prohibiting nut usage in the classroom or mandating nut usage either way.
I'd like to just read a section out of the Code of Ethics.
It's Responsibility to Students.
It's ED 510.02.
In fulfilling responsibilities to students, a credential holder shall maintain a professional relationship with all students, both inside and outside the educational setting, and make reasonable efforts to protect students from conditions which are harmful to their health and safety.
My concerns are that we are starting to get into this code of ethics and changing some of this stuff without working through the department where we have already stated in a letter to them that we would like to have things handled that way through the JLCAR process.
I totally agree that kids should not have to wear masks.
My grandkids, ages 3 12 right through the middle school that are living with me, shouted for joy today because today is the first day the West Barnett Village School does not require masks.
And they're all going and a little three and a half year old you couldn't believe his face you know of course he never wore it properly to begin with it was down around his neck and and so I think that you know for us to you know get into this right now through trying to mandate something in statute may be not the way we've always advocated as a group here certainly I believe it's choice I absolutely do believe it's choice and I think that that's where we should be and however we know now that the mask mandate is being eliminated many schools at this point So, at best, I would suggest that we think about an interim study on this and start looking at how this gels in with our code and how we move forward to deal with situations like this in the future that we've been encountering here for the last two and a half years.
Yes, Representative Nelson.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I understand where you're coming from.
I've also been at the other side where this could easily get blown out of proportion in the sense that how many other things are people going to come up with?
So I agree with the peanuts and I agree with where you're going, but I just think it could get out of hand with people making different demands as time goes on as so many things have happened so thank you mr.
chair again I look at this bill and I see it do exactly what you were speaking about mr.
chair as an option bill that this puts the onus on the parents to be responsible for their children if they choose to want to mask their child they tell to wear a mask.
If they choose not to, they don't have to.
I think the biggest thing this thing does is about the state, whether the state's going to force people who choose not to want to wear a mask to have to wear a mask, and then all of the implications that went around that, whether it was the shaming that occurred when a kid didn't wear a mask and had it down below and all that aggravation that occurred because we had a mandate versus an option.
And I think this bill goes a long way towards, again, making it back to the parent's choice to be able to allow a parent to make the medical decision for their child.
If the child is immunocompromised or medically fragile, they can choose to get an N95 mask or a bigger mask and manage that.
So I guess I look at this bill and I just see that we're putting, again, we're trusting parents with this bill.
We're saying parents are going to do the right thing, and I think they will when given the chance.
Thank you.
Further discussion on the bill?
Okay, I'm going to call a caucus on this right now.
And following caucus, we'll just go right into lunch.
So we won't, we are coming back.
After lunch.
Let's do it.
And following caucus, we'll just go right into lunch.
So we are coming back after lunch.
Let's just make it at 1 o'clock.
We'll come back.
Not until 1 o'clock.
Thank you.
We, of course, we left for a caucus.
We're going to recess any further action on the bill we were talking about, 1131, until later on this afternoon.
And with that, I'd like to jump on to the next bill I'm going to take up, and that's going to be HB 1261.
That's prohibiting the use of Native American mascots in public schools, colleges, and universities.
And I'd like to recognize Representative Boone for a motion.
Thank you, Mr.
Speaker, for 1261.
Mr.
what?
Don't upgrade me to anything, please.
I'm thinking ahead, Mr.
Chairman.
Thank you.
I'd like to recommend 1261 to ITL.
Is there a second?
I'll second.
Thank you.
So we have a motion made by Representative Boehm and seconded second by represent hobson itl is that motion prohibiting the use of native american mascots in public schools colleges and universities that's 1261.
you're recognized for for the discussion represent bohm thank you the reason i'm saying itl because one, this is a local school issue, and I find that using Native American Indian symbiology or whatever is inherently disrespectful.
That is not true.
To the contrary, such symbology was intended to honor various qualities and attributes of Native Americans.
Indeed, many polls show significant importance among Native Americans for continued association with sports teams and educational institutions.
One of the issues is, what about, why just North American names?
What about other groups?
For example, I found out some years ago I'm 25% Scandinavian.
I don't like Minnesota Vikings because of the bad thing about Vikings.
The same way, what about the Boston Celtics that have a mascot of a leprechaun?
To Celts around the world, that's totally not right.
I mean, so the thing is Thank you.
to Celts around the world, that's totally not right.
I mean, so the thing is, yeah, this is local control.
If they want to do it, and if, for example, like the Florida State Seminoles, that's licensed by the Seminoles.
So I think the same thing can happen here.
If any North American group wants wants their name they can ask for it or not ask for it in other words so it's a local control issue and the word warrior for example is not any group can be warriors so there's some problems with the designations thank you is there further discussion from the maker the second further discussion from the committee represent luno thank you very much mr chair so um so we're taking the uh the boil the ocean argument when it comes to the itl that uh that we cannot um in fact support the wishes of Native Americans who, among the eight people that came, or nine people that came to speak to the committee, all in favor, none opposed to this bill, including two people from the Grand Council of the Pentecook-Abenaki people who spoke very eloquently as to what this and how use of Native American mascots in public schools, colleges, and universities really doesn't honor them at all.
In fact, they feel completely different about it.
So it's interesting that we're choosing to ignore how Native Americans, or at least two that are representing the Pinnacook Abenaki, feel when it comes to public institutions that use their likeness and names as mascots.
You know, it's just I certainly understand the point that Representative Boehm makes when it comes to other mascots that might be used, whether in intercollegiate or interscholastic or professional sports.
And perhaps those can be taken up at a later time.
but when it comes to Native Americans, I think there's a lot we can do, and there's a lot that's being done, certainly in the professional sports world, to move away from taking advantage and disparaging them, certainly not honoring them by using those mascots.
So it's just, it's incredible that somehow this committee feels that while maybe the Boston Celtics are taking advantage of some group and the Minnesotanesota minnesota vikings are taking advantage of scandinavians that we can't stop that so we can't stop this but we can stop this because we've got a bill in front of us right now that that does it so i hope we can defeat the itl and um and look favorably upon this bill further discussion any handsackus.
I just wonder how much this is the objection of a few as opposed to the objection of the many, because I know there were a few in Cleveland who thought it was unreasonable to have the Cleveland Indians as the baseball team, and I know that after that got changed, many of the local Native Americans, of which I am a descendant, from that area, objected strongly to having the Cleveland Indians no longer the Cleveland Indians, because they were proud of that.
So I just want, you know, we heard from a few, and I'm just wondering how much is a few complaining.
And so I find it hard to pass a law based on a few, but I don't know.
Further discussion?
Representative Olson?
I didn't know who had their hand up over there.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
We pass laws all the time based on representation of just a few.
For instance, the education freedom accounts that were in House Bill 20 and eventually made its way into House Bill 2 with virtually no public support or certainly very little public support over tremendous public opposition.
So apparently we do this all the time, but only when we want to.
Further discussion?
Not seeing any.
Ms.
Clerk, would you call the roll, please?
Yes.
No.
No..
Representative Small.
No.
Representative Black.
Yes.
10 to 9.
Okay.
Okay, you can do that.
Another bill which we're going to jump to just to assist represent Boehm who's not going to be here tomorrow is 1639 this is relative to the youth risk behavior survey and schools represent boom looking for a motion thank you mr.
chairman and I recommend OTP and I also I have an amendment.
Is there a second to the OTP?
Second.
Who?
OTP and I also have an amendment is there a second to the OTP who made that I'm sorry me Oh Ford Oh Ford okay 1639 everybody's turning to it.
Representative Boehm, you made the motion.
Are you open to discussion?
Yes, I also have an amendment to the bill which fixes a grammatical error that was in the original bill.
The amendment is 0189 H.
What was that number again please?
0189 H.
the original bill...
Do we all have that?
I passed it out this morning.
Yeah.
Because I had it for a month.
Go ahead, Representative Bo.
Okay, thank you.
Go ahead, Representative Bohm.
Thank you.
The amendment just fixes on line 12, the original bill that said that allow requires, and that was fixed.
Sort of a grammatical error, I guess, when they did a cut and paste.
So that's the only thing the amendment does is fixes that but just just on the while the amendment just fixes that but on the whole thing is I guess we need to vote on the amendment first well you have to introduce the amendment I introduced it there was a second would you do it again please I like to make a motion on the amendment 0189H to 1639.
Is there a second?
Thank you.
Representative Hobson second.
Representative Bohm's motion for amendment 0189H.
The amendment, like I said, fixes a grammatical error on line 12 in the original bill.
Okay, that was on line 12 where it read provision that allow requires a parent.
Right, yeah.
Didn't make a whole lot of sense.
Right.
Okay.
Now you have that requires a okay further discussion on the amendment go ahead yeah um i can't support anything about this bill typo or not so i'm certainly not going to be supporting the amendment thank you further.
Further discussion?
Not seeing any?
Mr.
Clerk, would you please call the roll on the...
Well, we can do that in a show of hands with the amendment.
It's amendment 0189H.
Ought to pass.
Okay.
You're going to show a hand.
Is that what you said?
Yeah.
What we're doing.
Okay.
Those opposed?
10-9.
Okay.
Now we have the bill in front of us.
Will you make a motion, please, Representative Bohm?
Make a motion.
Author passed with the amendment.
Okay.
Second.
Yep.
of us would you make a motion please represent bone make a mention off the pass with amendment okay yep further discussion yeah those members bill is on the youth risk behavior survey which we found from different testimony and and I don't even know the person that pretty much dittoed my presentation.
Most school kids, especially in high school, don't take these things seriously.
It's taken as a joke.
And I remember when we did it in our school, I mean, the kids were taking it as pretty much as a joke.
And it's not an anonymous survey because you had to do the first six, seven questions, and pretty much in any school you can determine who the person is, except for what we heard in testimony, people just lying about even, about who they are, what race they are, how much they weigh, what sex they are, and everything.
So the thing is, if that's all taken as a joke, including what if a student was taking drugs, will they say that on that survey?
I don't think so.
So they're not going to say anything illegal.
When it happened in our school some years ago, I heard from my spies in the school, some students and whatnot, that this was all a joke.
Then when our principal came in with the disastrous surveys, I mean, and I told him and the school board that, and backed up by the student representative of the school board that the students took us as a joke.
So the thing is, DHHS saying we need this information for all these studies and whatnot.
What good is a study when people are lying about their identity?
They're lying about drugs.
They're just answering the questions as if, hey, it's funny.
It's a fun thing they do.
They do it on Facebook.
How are we going to answer these questions?
Thank you.
about drugs to just answering the questions as if hey it's funny it's a fun thing they do they do it on Facebook how are we going to answer these questions so if this bill is it's a waste of time and I think it needs to be opt-in just like every other survey so let the parents know and and look at the survey before they allow their kids to take the survey.
Representative Mullen.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So New Hampshire has been administering the Youth Behavior Risk Survey for 29 years.
And during the hearing, we heard from the National Institute of Mental Illness.
We heard from New Futures.
We heard from the Department of Public Health.
In the interim, we have heard from the Raymond Coalition of Youth, from the drug coordinator of the anti-drug program in Dover, and the police chief out of Franklin, New Hampshire.
And all of those people spoke impassionedly about the importance of this survey.
When you conduct a survey of this nature, and I speak with some authority because I've administered it and I spent I spent 27 professional years using the results there are two metrics that are involved in a survey like this one is referred to as validity the other is referred to as reliability and there what that translates into is that the creators of a measure like this build into the measure certain patterns of answers that rule a test in or out as valid and reliable.
So if somebody were to draw pictures with their penciled-in answer on the test or on the survey, or if they were to answer questions in a manner that came across as particularly skewed, the results of that test or survey would not be included in the aggregate scores.
We have heard over and over and over again, in Bedford, New Hampshire, we have an organization called Be Bold.
And the goal of that organization is drug and alcohol awareness and prevention and assisting youth in healthy lifestyles.
It is a group of very active parents and professionals who have spoken to me at length about making sure that this remains a carve-out and that we continue to administer the youth behavior risk survey.
We plan parent nights, we plan programs in the schools, we disseminate information, we participate in Red Ribbon Week.
A lot of what we offer to parents and students is based upon the results, which are in fact posted on the school district website.
A lot of the programming depends upon the results that come out of this.
And if you read, I understand that we received like 1,000 emails last week, not about this, but in general.
So you may not have actually seen the information that came in from Dover and from Raymond.
I wish you would have the opportunity before we had to vote on this to read it and to see the community impact that this survey has in developing programs.
with regards to the opt-in and opt-out parents already have a choice they already all they have to do is notify the school and tell them that they don't want their student to participate, and they don't participate.
So it's not that this is being forced on anyone.
And I've heard the argument over and over again about if they can return a field trip permission slip, then they can return this.
Well, the reality is, you know how children are.
You wouldn't be sitting on this committee if you didn't.
Children will respond to a preferred activity in a way that is quite different than others.
So it's not equitable.
There is an out for any family that does not want to participate in this.
But adding this layer of bureaucracy, jeopardizing the number of responses that come back.
We heard from the people who testified in front of us that if a certain percentage of the student body does not participate, then the results are invalid, and funding is challenged, and programs go away.
1993 was the first year that the Youth Risk Behavior Survey was given in New Hampshire.
Why are we trying to take it away now?
Thank you.
Further discussion, Representative Likas?
I have just a few things to say.
One is that I was always taught garbage in, garbage out.
And if you're basing your results and what you're going to do on something that, and I have heard from not just our wonderful representative over here, but from various other kids and whatever, that they do not answer that accurately.
So if you're basing your things on inaccurate ends, you're going to get inaccurate outs.
Number two, there's lots of good things that are going on.
Why do we need a survey to do them?
Why don't we just do them?
We know there's some of these issues in the schools.
Why don't we just do the programs that they're doing?
Why do we need a survey to be able to do the programs?
But the third one is, well, it's already on there, and the parents just have to opt out.
Here's the problem.
I remember when my granddaughter, who was living with us when she was in high school, and took this, and she came home.
She was very upset because of the personal questions that were being asked, and she was not the kind of person who even wants to talk about those things and to have to answer this survey.
I was on the school website every day.
I was talking to her teachers every day, making sure her homework was done, making sure how she was doing.
I never saw an announcement that said that this was coming up because I would have opted her out of it because I knew what her feelings were about something like this.
And so somewhere on that website it probably existed, but I was on there every day talking to teachers looking at her results they have a great website never saw it didn't know until she came home very upset so and I've heard this from other you heard parents who came in and talked about kids who came and said kids who were young who home and said, Mom, should I be having sex?
Because it was on the survey.
I mean, a lot of parents were upset about this.
That's why it got changed a long time ago to parent opt-in, not parent opt-out, because parents were very upset.
And so it got changed back to opt-out.
At any rate, we really, I think, that's what I have to say.
Thank you.
Representative Tanner.
I guess I had written down the points that Representative Lekas made.
I think Representative Mullen made a great point about how surveys are done.
This is a survey that's done by very professional people, and they certainly know how to make the validity and reliability of the responses.
So I think the whole thing about garbage in, garbage out is really garbage in, garbage out as well.
I think the other thing is that as a health teacher um you know you just and and the kids as well i think you hear rumors all the time and parents hear rumors all the time and and you know one or two people can be talking about something just like our Indian mascot.
And do you refer that what you take in as a personal rumor or an antidote?
Or do you take that as applicable to everybody?
Or is it better to have a survey that's done professionally that allows results that then give you a picture of the whole rather than just of the few kids that come?
Thank you.
that allows results that then give you a picture of the whole rather than just of the few kids that come.
And I guess my third part of it, because I did teach health, and there was a section on sex education, and it was ninth graders.
And some ninth graders are ready for it and some aren't.
Some ninth grade parents are ready for it, and some ninth grade parents are ready for it and some ninth grade parents are not and um they had an opt out for it they could come and see the curriculum they they um parents could could do that and some of them did and and had their own uh discussion and whatever but you know one of the things about kids going through school is that they have a point where discussions need to happen.
And sometimes it's unfortunate that the parents get kind of put in the position that they have to discuss maybe before they're ready.
But I don't think that's necessarily any more from this risk survey than it is from what they hear in the hall, hear on the bus, hear from their friends.
I think that's where a lot of the misinformation comes from.
And so this survey is very important if you're any kind of health or wellness field to get a real, you know, picture from 100 feet up rather than anecdotally.
And I think we're doing a very big disservice to put more restrictions on it that's going to effectively make it less valid and less reliable and less accessible.
So that's my bit.
Thank you very much.
Representative Nelson.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
From my experiences, these are rigged, fake results when you ask one of those surveys.
So I'm assuming if it had something to do with masks and they all decided to do one thing or another, you would accept it.
In other if the school the kids all in the school voted no mask whatsoever and you know some wanted it because they wanted to be popular would you think that would be a good idea in other words false information one of the people asked one of the entities asking us to continue continue this as an opt-out is our own New Hampshire Health and Human Services Department, and they stated how useful they found it is, and I don't think they would go by false information.
It is one of our own state departments, and I don't think they make things up when saying that they liked it and found it useful and didn't want it to be an opt-in.
And to get into the opt-in, I too worked in a school for many years.
And when you talk about kids remember bringing things in for field trips, I remember making phone calls to parents on the morning of a field trip because their kids were crying because they weren't going to be able to go, asking them to please bring in the permission slip so that the kid could go on the field trip.
So they don't remember to bring things home to show them either way.
So it's not that they remember when it's something they want to do.
It happens, it depends on the kid if they remember to bring it in or not.
But I don't think we can say that it's not useful information when so many respected New Hampshire Health and Human Services, NAMI, think they can really use this.
Thank you.
Further discussion?
Representative Luno?
Thanks very much.
And actually, I'd seen Representative Mullen's hand go up after the last question, too, and I think I want to take that up because unlike the scenario that Representative Nelson says with a single question, the YRBS is a number of questions, and the survey is designed by professionals in order to be able to protect the validity and reliability of the data, and that can be determined.
I'm sure it is some sort of statistical analysis that goes into looking at not only how each question is answered in order to determine the validity of each one of those responses and therefore maximize the reliability of the data that's collected.
We heard specifically from Chief Goldstein and his quote is that the YRBS produces legitimate results.
And I suspect due to the chief's education in this area, he has a strong understanding of both those survey design parameters to protect validity and ensure reliability of the data.
Representative Mullen also listed out several groups, New Futures, NAMI, DHHS for Public Health, the Coalition Against Domestic and Sexual Violence, all speaking in opposition to this bill.
the Department of Health and Human Services further goes on, and I am paraphrasing because it's in the second-to-last paragraph of the letter that Director Tilly provided the committee.
And basically it goes on to say that a district that does not have YRBS data may not be able to apply for grants that could support students and districts with identified needs related to behavioral health or substance use disorders.
And really important for, I would dare say, all communities across the state of New Hampshire, but I think there's certain communities that do run into very acute conditions of behavioral health and substance use and disorder that would, because of this, because of a bill like this, may be denied the ability to apply for grants and run programs to protect kids and their families.
So, you know, I understand that some people may have, you know, anecdotal information coming from spies that among, you know, kids in school that don't take it seriously.
In fact the the the survey the analysis process for the survey would would would show the lack of validity and in some of those survey completions and and still the results would would be reliable useful for those communities and incredibly useful useful as far as applying for grants to run the programs that help these kids and help their families.
So I hope we can overturn the ought to pass and go with the straight opposition that we heard from so many qualified and credible organizations, government organizations as well as non-government organizations across the state and how important this survey data is.
Thank you.
Further discussion.
I'm also going to try to remind everybody that we're going to try to get through some of these bills today.
So let's try to hustle a little bit, Representative Ling.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
I'm looking at this bill, and I guess I go back to, you know, I'm a technologist by trade.
The default privacy for a technologist is you ask to collect data, not just take the data first, and then say, oh, if you don't want me to do it, I'll erase it from my system.
So you always ask first before you collect the data.
And this also goes in line with, remember back in 2018, we passed our right to privacy law, a constitutional amendment.
Over 80% of New Hampshire citizens said, and I'll quote the statute, agreed with a statement that says, an individual's right to live free from governmental intrusion and private and personal information is natural, essential, and inherent.
So when I look at this and the idea of asking parents, especially how personal these questions are, as I just went through and read the 2021 survey, how personal some of these questions are asking about drug use and sex and whether you've tried alcohol, whether it's alcohol, guns in your home kind of questions.
Those kind of things are extremely personal and extremely private.
And to protect our citizens and go in alignment with our constitutional provision, 85% said they don't want the government to collect this data unless we give them a chance to say, yes, you can have my data.
So I look at this strictly, besides whether you believe any of the data is accurate or not accurate the first provision is no matter what your need is for the data you have to first get permission for it and that's why I'll be voting to support yes represent Porter they do get permission first parents can opt out if parents opt out that's saying they don't want this information given if parents don't opt out it means it's fine with them to have the information given so I think that's a permission that's what opt out and I'll tell you based on the constitutional amendment that was passed in that data we just just over in HHS is passing an opt-in for the registry, is that because of the changes in our constitution and the law, and again, changes in data as technologists, that the fact is that now the privacy standard is you ask for data before you take the data.
That's the technology standard.
Further discussion?
Not seeing any.
Mr.
Clerk's the technology standard.
Further discussion?
Not seeing any.
Mr.
Clerk, would you please call the rule?
This is on Bill 1639, amendment.
We've done the amendment, right?
Doesn't have...
As amended.
Yes, as amended, yes.
Thank you.
Mine's working.
This one is too.
That one's working.
Yes.
There we go.
Mine's on 1639.
Correct.
Representative Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Lang.
Representative Boehm.
Yes.
Representative Leacus.
Representative LaSalle.
Yes.
Hopson.
Representative Hopson.
Yes.
Representative Ford.
Representative Sodai.
Yes.
Representative Nelson.
Representative Luno.
No.
Representative Wellner.
Representative Cornell.
No.
Representative Tanner.
Absolutely not.
Representative Ellison.
No.
Representative Tanner.
Absolutely not.
Representative Ellison.
No.
Representative Mullen.
Representative Mary.
No.
Representative Porter.
Representative Hall.
No.
Representative Ladd.
Yes.
10-9.
Okay.
We have one other bill that Representative Bowman is doing.
HB 1663, this bill relative to requirements for home education students.
Are there amendments for this bill?
So we'll have discussion first.
Thank you.
guys it's being passed out representative bohm are you going to introduce the amendment yes okay let's let everybody get it yeah okay the amendment we play it keeps the first sections one and two.
Why don't you give us the amendment number first?
Okay, 0398H.
Discussion.
Okay.
The amendment keeps items one and two, and this is amend the bill by replacing all after section two with the following okay so after section two section three is a new one and add some new language a move this and previously notified the resident district superintendent as part of it I mean the thing is yeah it strikes out the and so in addition to okay for that part of it and then the rest of it it's all new language best we say in the portfolio at all times remains the property of the parent okay with the child the sec line 22 adds in and or disability the parent the child shall be deemed to have successfully completed an annual evaluation upon meeting requirements of any of the following and what's removed on line 28 where it says complete results at or above the 40th percentile such days shall be deemed reasonable academic proficiency.
The issue there is in public schools, we don't make any difference between what a child passes on the annual evaluation or if a school, entire school is below the 40th percentile.
Nothing happens to them.
So the same thing for homeschool students.
Why did they be treated any differently?
Also, the child on line 30 or 31 removes that composite results out of both the 40th percent I should be deemed reasonable the same thing I had said before it's it's not it's it's the same pretty much the same as public school students okay and then authority of school district officials no superintendent school board and and adds ends with and the predictions of this chapter period and any rules pursuant RSA 193 83 so it includes the whole 193 and home education and so everything else is pretty much what's in 193 now so those were the changes Okay, is there further discussion on this from the committee?
Any questions?
Okay, Representative Tanner?
Yes.
is the intent of this, like when you took out in addition, that only the Commissioner of Education possibly could be receiving these portfolios or test results?
Is that what your intent is in line five?
Thank you.
or the non-public school principal within 15 days of said termination.
That's just, I'm not going to do it anymore.
So you can file the commission with the commissioner, the student, the district superintendent, or a non-public school, which is pretty much, and now I think the and in addition was just messed up.
Yeah.
So you can file with.
I understood it as the and in addition was that they filed it with the commissioner and in addition they could do the resident district superintendent or the non-public school principal.
I think, I mean, initially, the and in addition, no, it should be basically it's either, I mean, any of the above, whatever you filed initially.
Because right now when you file file you don't have to file with your school you can file with the commissioner or if you're going to or a principal in a non-public school and not in addition to you just doing it just repealing what you had done before when you filed represent cordiallyelli.
Thank you.
Maybe a question for Representative Boehm.
So this is making the termination notification consistent with the notification to home school.
Right.
Definitely.
Further discussion?
Yes.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, for taking my questions.
So the question I have is with reference to lines 18 and 19.
What happens if a student comes in and out of the homeschool and public school spheres?
Does this potentially mean that a body of evidence may not exist if they're homeschooled for two years and maybe then back in the public school sphere for three years and then potentially would come back out?
What happens to that body of evidence and work?
It's up to the parent.
If the parent is going to do that, then they have to prove that the child has taken the prerequisites, for example, in those schools, or the school does not have to allow it.
I mean, the prerequisite there, and so if the home school is going to do that, allow the students, which they can, go to a public school for one class, they have to prove that they met the prerequisite, say, for that chemistry class or that calculus class.
So it just leaves it up to the parent as to what information they keep.
Further discussion?
Yes, Representative Lekas.
Well, I would think that information that was three years old, a portfolio that was three years old wouldn't be that particularly important anyways I mean as a parent I kept all of mine and all the parents that I know have all the portfolios kept but if you're if you're talking about evaluation and something a three-year-old portfolio you want to see this year's portfolio anyways so whether or not they kept a three-year-old portfolio shouldn't make a whole lot of difference should it Rep.
Santa Porter yes but you could say the same thing for the grades that the kid earned in third grade you know when they're in sixth grade do they really matter well yeah they're part of the kid's record so there's evidence that learning and was continuing over the period of time further discussion yes represent mullen thank you mr.
chair on the second page of the amendment line 9 begins 7, the repeal of home education rulemaking.
Am I correct that this would remove the State Board of Education from any of the rulemaking for homeschooled students?
Correct.
And additional rules will expire when they expire.
So my follow-up, I guess, to you, Representative Boehm, is who's going to make the rules?
Nobody.
The law is the law.
We don't need rules based on the law.
For example, and this was in the original law, which was done in 2011 and passed in 2012, where the only school districts and whatnot can only pass laws based on 193.
So the problem is the rules which, when I first did this back Back in 2011, I chaired a subcommittee to come up with rules and the 193 initially I had it as the rules came from the Home Education Advisory Council, not from the Board of Ed.
The Senate took that part out.
But the thing is, there are very few rules now, and there doesn't need to be any.
It's the parent's responsibility.
And if they want to go back and forth to the public schools...
The thing is, there's very few rules now, and there doesn't need to be any.
It's the parent's responsibility.
And if they want to go back and forth to the public school, they've got to prove to the public school.
I mean, there shouldn't be any rules.
Thank you.
Representative Cordelli.
there have been an issue with rules in the past in that rules were put in place that went way beyond what is in the statutes.
And rules made it more restrictive on homeschool parents.
So this is a protection against that type of activity or the activity possibly in the future where the state board might want to loosen up home education rules beyond what is in law.
It would guard against both sides of that.
Further discussion?
Representative Cornell.
It seems to me that things are changing.
When we were discussing 11-14 earlier, we said we didn't have to put things into law because we had them in rules.
But now we're saying we don't have to put we can get rid of the rules because we're putting things into law.
So is it different for a different thing?
Didn't we just say that we didn't need to put something in law because we had it in rules?
But now we're saying that it should be in law because we can do away with the rules.
Reverend Cordelli.
Thank you.
I think in terms of home education statutes are very clear as to the processes and the requirements.
So I think that there is no need for the rules, whereas possibly other programs, more complicated programs with more requirements might need rules for clarification purposes and processes to be followed within the executive branch.
Further discussion?
Not seeing any.
any okay we've just gone through the discussion phase now we we need to yeah we need to have this amendment okay I move Amendment 0398 H for OTP I have a motion on the floor that this amendment we just looked at 0398 H is moved ought to pass to be amended to the bill itself.
Made by Representative Boehm, seconded by Representative Likas.
Any further discussion?
Representative, Mr.
Clerk.
Thank you.
Motion is ought to pass.
On amendment.
On is ought to pass.
On the amendment.
Okay.
All right.
Representative Cordelli.
You can raise hands or you can do it the other way.
It's up to you.
Raise hands.
Nose.
Nose?
Okay, thank you.
Okay, Representative Boone, now they can make a motion.
No, Mr.
Chair, I'd like to move amendment 973H.
973H.
Everybody should have a copy.
It's stapled.
Got a staple through the corner of it.
But no holes.
I asked for holes, but I got no holes.
It's okay.
We asked for a lot around here.
It's got a staple in the corner.
I have more.
Wait a minute.
This has staples in it.
No, that one where all the amendments end up, the extras.
We're on 1663-0973H.
No, I...
Same bill.
It may have been given to me.
I need an extra amendment, please.
Okay, we're going to have to take a little second minute here.
We have a...
Clerk's...
Oh, 0973?
For up oh those are visiting us this is our backup clerk to the backup okay we're all set we're all set good thank you okay would you please explain the motion or no I'd be happy to thank very much, Mr.
Chair.
So, Amendment 973H is a lighter touch, I think, on 1663 as introduced.
And just going through what it does, it actually strikes Section 1 from the bill.
and section one really doesn't do anything because it already requires that home-educated pupils shall have access to curricular courses and curricular programs offered by a school district.
So that's already there regardless of whether a school district actually has a written policy on that.
So they already have access to those resources provided by the public school.
So it picks up from the original bill on line 14 with section 2 and mirrors all of that, brings it through, actually mirrors all of that with the exception of Roman 3.
So now I'm on page 19 of the, I'm sorry, line 19 of the amendment, which corresponds to line 30 of the bill, and I think straightens out some of the somewhat confusing language about what happens when a student leaves one is homeschooling, leaves one district, goes to another district, and potentially withdraws from homeschooling at that point, who gets notified.
and rather than notifying the the department of education it really vests notification with the with the superintendent at the district of residence since they're the ones that that really do have the sort of the the child find responsibility and the responsibility to make sure that students are in compliance with the attendance statute.
That's actually with the superintendent, so not the department.
So that's what the very light touch changes at Roman 3 do.
I think a very important part of this bill is carried through in section 3 of the amendment, which is section 4 of the original bill, which eliminates the composite result, the student's performance having to be above the 40th percentile, which is just not going to be possible for every student.
So that carries through in Section 3, and then it concludes in Section 3, let's see, just as the bill was written, and then the final thing the amendment does is it deletes Section 5 from the original bill, which I think Representative Boehm's amendment also does.
Yeah, actually, it deletes Representative Boehm's amendment also deletes the same language.
which just deletes a little bit more in any rules adopted pursuant to a...!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
also repeals 193A colon 3 rulemaking completely, which I think is really a heavy-duty change.
So, like I said, I think this is the amendment that I'm proposing here.
973 is a lighter touch.
I think it captures the important elements that come through in the bill and preserves the limited rulemaking that the department has in this area.
That's all I got.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
In looking at the bill as introduced, I'm looking at Section 5, Home Educated Students.
It talks about authority of the school district officials and talks about when a child comes back in from homeschooling into the rigor program.
That's also alluded to in the amendment which we just passed in section 8, the classroom placement of a formerly home-educated student.
It reads in the one we did, a student who was home-educated in accordance with 193a and is enrolling in public schools, shall be placed according to their age unless the parent and school agree otherwise.
In the bill as it was introduced, there are other factors which come into play.
In yours, I don't see anything.
How do we reconcile all this?
Obviously, the bill as amended would replace what was in the introduction bill has introduced and it says we place by age right but but you how I guess that's that's something that that may be very difficult for a um for a district of a school district of residents to do not knowing what the uh the student has done and in particular if um if uh if a family is placing a student uh taking them out withdrawing from the homeschool environment and placing a student into the school district let's say June of their of the let's say they're 17 years old and and they would technically be a senior and graduation is 10 days later and the school district has not been provided any proof of any competencies or any student outcomes whatsoever, but at that point would be required, I guess, to graduate the student and provide them with a high school diploma, not knowing what courses, if any, the student actually completed.
And I think that puts the school district in an untenable position.
And just follow-up, as introduced it says unless students within the school are stratified or placed by academic performance so that's another way of placing whereas what we've just done says they're placed in accordance with their age, and as you've introduced, it doesn't have it in the bill.
No, it's as currently is in law.
Oh, as currently in law.
And I apologize, Mr.
Chair.
It's very difficult to look at current law.
The bill is introduced, the Boehm Amendment, and the Luno Amendment.
Yeah, I'm not looking at statutes, so I'm just looking at what I have here.
Yeah.
Yes, Representative Cordelli.
Thank you you I believe that section one as in the is important in changing the may to shall for a policy because we actually had an instance where a homeschooled child was denied access to extracurricular activities.
The parent went to the department.
The department actually had to file a suit against the school district before they recognized that they were in error and let the student participate in that activity.
So I think that requiring the policy and recognition of some of this in policy is needed.
So a follow-up on that.
That's not the primary purpose of the amendment that I'm offering.
I could certainly let Section 1, would certainly support Section 1 coming back in.
I just don't see it as being necessary because if in the case that you, the situation that you just laid out, with or without a policy, that school shall provide access to the curricular courses and co-curricular programs for a homeschooled student.
So they're clearly in violation of state law, regardless of whether they have a policy on that.
But I'm fine to put that back in if we want to try to do a committee amendment that, you know, merges the Boehm amendment and the Luno amendment and the bill is introduced.
I know that when we initially wrote this legislation years and years ago, in fact, I wrote it, for a student that's not in the public school or is in a charter school or some other educational arena and they want to come and participate in the athletic program or the theater program or something in the co-curricular area, then their school district does have policy.
And the same policy and expectations of a student in the public school as you're passing your courses or you've got a certain average and you're not delinquent as far as coming to school, that same policy would be appropriate for the person coming.
So the game is fair on both sides and equal.
That I do not want to see disturbed.
I think that's very important.
I was in charge of athletics for the school district where we were, and we sometimes saw that a student that was unable to muster the academic levels, then went on a different level and then came back and said, yeah, I want to participate in this hockey program.
And our primary purpose, of course, is academics.
And so we disallowed.
And that was a district where we had tremendous dollars for athletics.
Our travel budget alone was $1.5 million dollars this was in Alaska so I think that same formula or intent was put into law right in this state when we initially put this together I think represent boom you're on the committee at that time when we did it definitely yeah and I think that one of the problems we had in up by public school we had it kids can go to what came to athletics though the problem was Thank you.
And I think that one of the problems we had in our public school, when we had it, the kids can go to what came to athletics, though.
The problem was to have to make the team.
And we had one case where the homeschool student didn't make the team.
So the parents moved to Nashua and made the Nashua team.
Wait a minute.
You didn't make the small school team, but you made the big city school team.
So, yeah, there are still problems with that.
Thank you.
the Nashua team.
Wait a minute.
You didn't make the small school team, but you made the big city school team.
So yeah, there are still problems with that, but the law has got to be, you know, you have the opportunity.
It's got to be fair.
So Mr.
Chair, I guess I'm not sure then how we follow what you're just saying, given the fact that Representative Boehm's bill repeals rulemaking in Section 7, because clearly you do need to have some rulemaking when it comes to, and I agree with you, Mr.
Chair, it's not so much participation in co-curricular activities, but that's part of it, but in terms of academics and where to place a student who returns to a school district, that should be laid out in rules based on law.
and and honestly I think if you wanted to for the in order to be expedient maybe really the only things that need to be addressed here are in section 2 of the original bill which is eliminating those sentences in B and C about composite results above the 40th percentile.
You know, maybe we need to take a little more care on the rest of it.
Mr.
Chair, could I ask a question?
Sure.
Back to that idea of the returning student being placed by age, how would that work in a high school setting?
I don't know.
You know, that's the question, and that's part of why I brought this thing up, because it's easy to do that in the lower L, but when you talk about getting into the intermediate level, especially when you start like sixth grade, which is considered middle school in some, we have middle school in four through eight in some locations in the state, but when you get in the upper levels of middle school, you're now starting to also get offerings that are offered at the high school level, presented in the 7th and 8th grades now, especially in the mathematics areas and that.
So this is getting into an area where it's not just age places.
We place based upon the competencies.
We place upon where they're achieving.
And we look at maturation as well.
So there's a whole lot here.
There's one area I know that we all agree on, that the 40th percentile is an area that needs to be gone.
We are looking now more at growth and achievement, and certainly we want to see some some growth but 40th percentile that was an old denominator used years ago and it needs to be gone so mr chair would it be reasonable to offer a um a committee amendment or possibly amendment from represent bohm and myself that restores um uh section one from the original bill which is what represent cordelli was talking about assuring access having a policy that assures access to curriculum and co-curricular activities and then uh and then having a another section that takes away the 40th percentile.
And just until we get a better understanding of what the rest does, leave it alone.
Well, you mentioned yourself and Representative Boehm.
Let's see what Mr.
Boehm wants to say.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just offering that.
Just one thing on age difference.
You're in high school.
What age?
So it's really not.
I mean, you can be 13 and be a senior.
You can be 18 and be a freshman.
I mean, so age really doesn't matter in a high school.
No, Representative Boehm, if I may, Mr.
Chair, my question was exactly that.
It was not, you know, can you go to high school when you're 13?
It's if somebody's returning back to school at age 15, where does that put them?
Is he a junior?
Is he a sophomore?
You know, how does that determination get made by age?
Yeah, I mean, it depends on, I mean, your portfolio, your school, your testing, whatever.
At that point in high school, since there isn't any age different.
So I don't think it's an issue.
Representative Lekas?
Yeah, the age part is in the original bill.
I'm not finding it in the amendment at all.
And in the original bill, it said, on line 15 on the second page you know the amendment replaces that aspect of it in a reps like this is correct it's in the amendment we just looked at.
The amendment replaces everything below.
According to their age, unless the parent and school agree otherwise.
And so in a high school, if the, you know, the original says unless they're already being stratified, right?
So in this case, it would be the parent in school to work out would it not you where where they belong well it'd be depending upon yet in the high school you're talking what happens if the parent and school don't agree because this is if and is there not or and what happens if the we're looking at the number of courses which were required for graduation then there's going to have to be some kind of a competencies you know done somewhere along the way to find out you know just like they do down University of Maryland for people in the service, they try to figure out what's going to count as a course as general ed.
So we'd have to have that process in place to determine where to place them, but we're not placing based on age, are we?
We're placing based upon knowledge and skills.
So we've got to be careful with this one.
Just because they're 15 doesn't mean they come in as a sophomore.
That's no different from a student coming from a different state.
And they come into school in their age.
I know in our school, a lot of schools, they give a student the test to see where they're at.
In some cases, they skip a grade.
I've seen that happening because their school where they came from was better.
I think the parent in the school agrees.
If they don't agree, the parent can continue the homeschooling.
Or they make, okay, that, or they make, okay, we need this.
If it takes this course, then we can do it.
We have within law here, if you look at the military compact, and when a student comes in that's in military, families military, there are conditions and steps that must be taken, and that's done through all 50 states in our country.
We are all part of that.
Now come in from a school in another state let's say Connecticut and they're coming in from an accredited school down in Connecticut then of course that's a different deal too they probably are going to be placed where their their file shows they belong but the principal of school I as a principal would certainly take a healthy look at this and determine well I going to place this kid in some kind of an AP course or am I going to go rigor ed or am I going to put where this child really belongs so that the child's not going to be overwhelmed and going to gain the knowledge that they need to have.
So I'm a little leery about just placing by age.
I think that's not going to work on the high school level at all.
I think what we need to do is that, and as Representative Cordelli just mentioned to me quietly, maybe we need to do some more work on this.
Maybe we need to, you can't retain it, but we could interim study it.
And because this is important.
You can't retain it, but we could interim study it.
Because this is important.
Representative Tanner, you got your hand up?
I just wanted to say that I think the home advisory group should be involved in this, that we should get some feedback from them.
And if we had an interim study, that would be a great...
I concur with you.
Could we work out something to just move the language from the original bill on lines 31 to 34 in terms of academic performance and substitute that for age in the BOMA amendment?
So we know we have a homeschool community, which is split, in terms of how they perceive home education.
We know that.
And I don't think there's anything so imperative in this bill that we have to do it right now.
And if I also know, PI, that we have about a day and a half left to get this work done.
I don't think we should be putting a whole lot more off before we deal with the other 25 bills we haven't dealt with yet today.
Mr.
Chair?
Yes.
Could we recess this until tomorrow and give me a chance tonight to talk to the chair of the HIAC, the Home Education Advisory Council, to see if they've had input to this.
I think all the input we can have is there, but I'd like to also have input from the High School Principals Association and find out where they are on it.
Pardon me?
Oh, great.
so yeah so that might be an angle but are they going to be able to get that information to you other than one person or I could at least check and see if they've discussed this in he act yeah so I was not at the last meeting I think we need to recess this bill right now and if if we go forward with it, we can always come forward with more work tomorrow.
If we can gain any, if any of us got hit by a bolt of lightning on this topic, maybe we can go forward.
If not, maybe we ought to be looking at a study of some kind.
Any objections to that?
Okay, let's move on.
Yeah, we approved the amendment, and there was a motion on the bill.
We have not acted on the bill as amended.
Pardon me?
We just did the one?
Yeah.
Okay.
This is education for all those people.
We move a little slower than they do maybe in commerce, but we try to get the job done.
The next bill, I don't think Representative Boehm has any more missiles for us.
Okay, let's keep walking down through where we were.
We were at 11.31.
Did we get any kind of feedback on that one over lunch?
Any, you know, we broke for caucus?
Or we can go on if we haven't gotten that yet.
Okay, we'll go on.
Okay.
Can we pick an easy one?
Okay, HB 1196, that's good.
Relative to school financial reports of public academies.
Okay, here, take the gavel.
This is 1196 and I'll ask representative I'll make a motion of ITL Second you second second by resident of Luno comments from chair I'd like to read the blurb this bill requires that public academies file a financial report each year to the Department of Education as an Academy pickington Academy is a unique independent learning school and its mission is to strive to ensure the growth of all students in a challenging, respectful, and collaborative environment.
It is an independent high school with contracts with area school districts and independent applicants, which serve 3,100 students in grades 9 through 12.
During the previous year, the Academy operated an extensive program of studies, including more than 320 unique courses and 60 co-curricular activities.
Having reviewed the most recent tax reports, the Academy is a not-for-profit organization exempt from federal and state income tax under Section 501c3.
The Academy has adopted accounting policy and has communicated to the committee Pinkerton Academy's tax exempt status and exemptions are identified in tax reporting and this material is publicly available the committee views this bill is unnecessary the second or have any comment exactly the same thoughts any further comment from the committee or maybe we can move straight to a uh roll call yes yes Yes.
Representative Ellison.
Representative Lullen.
Yes.
Representative Mary.
Representative Porter.
Yes.
Representative Mary.
Representative Porter.
Yes.
Representative Paul.
Representative Ladd.
Yes.
18.
Zip.
Yeah, one is absent.
Any problems with consent?
Okay.
Thank you.
any problems with consent okay what one was what you say Dave okay let's go to 1402ative to inclusion of charter public schools in school district bond issuance quotes.
1402.
Well, I tell you, I've mentioned many times, if I had got a dime every time I've turned these pages, I wouldn't have to buy any more gas this year.
I don't know.
Yeah any more gas this year.
Maybe I would.
If walking down the hall with one of you guys at noon to him I mentioned what we get paid with that $100 a year will fill our car up twice.
Once?
An 18-wheeler takes about $1,400 to fill it up once.
300-gallon tank.
Okay, what are we on here?
1402.
Okay, this is relative to inclusion of charter public schools and school district bond issuance votes.
We need a motion.
You don't have to make it.
Do you want to make it?
Representative Luno will write another one.
Oh, no.
I'm happy to.
I'll move ITL.
You want a second, Rep.
Scoredelli?
I will second.
So we have a motion on table on 1402.
ITL made by Representative Luno and seconded by Representative Cordelli.
Discussion on the bill, Representative Luno?
Sure, just very quickly.
You know, while I think there's good intentions behind this, I think there's a number of very specific aspects that that are not considered in this in this bill and it's something that should have uh you know uh be considered as more of a comprehensive look when it comes to the building um i'm sorry the bonding uh authority so uh so i think at this point um you know we're not going to be able to fix everything here.
So ITL, I think, is the right place for this.
Representative Cordelli?
Nothing further?
Any further discussion?
All those in favor?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
We can't do that.
Yeah.
I know we're trying to move.
Representative Nelson.
Roll call.
Oh, yes.
Representative Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Lange.
Representative Bowen.
Thank you.
Reps.
Nelson roll yes yes yes yes yes yes yes.
Yes.
There were a number of financial issues dealing with the bonding on property values and all that and it's just of the organization.
Mr.
18 that's right give me a jingle I didn't look over there I I wouldn't have done that.
No, no, no.
We're all right.
Okay.
I'd like to go to 1263.
We're going to have some amendments on this bill.
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
We will do that.
1263.
I'm going to try and get all the amendments here for this bill.
Let's see what we got.
I think we only have one amendment on this one.
There's two.
Okay, we have 0-9-2-3-H, and what's the other one?
0-9-7-4-H.
9-7-4-H.
Do you have it, Rick?
Yeah.
Probably somewhere.
Which one is this?
This is 1263.
Yeah, we do have.
The one I gave you was 1236.
That's not right.
So we're talking 1263.
Yeah, there's several amendments here yeah yes there are no we got two yeah okay we have zero nine four two h and zero nine seven four h We have 0942H and 0974H.
Can you remember those numbers for me again, please?
0942H and 0974H.
Okay.
What we're going to do is just open up to have a discussion.
We'll discuss both of these amendments and show the likenesses and differences between them, and then move forward and hopefully get it resolved.
Do you want to go first with yours, Representative Luno?
Sure, sure.
Thanks very much, Mr.
Chair.
I think both amendments try to accomplish very similar things by basically hijacking, I'll use that term, House Bill 1263.
and using that section to basically put an emphasis on wellness education and also to capture, I think, the intention that we heard in a different bill with respect to healthy relationships and respect for personal boundaries.
And the amendment that I'm offering, 974, uses that terminology in here.
It rolls out the PE number of minutes per week for physical education, which I think was the initial purpose.
Both amendments do that.
I think Representative Ladd's amendment uses language not the same as healthy personal relationships in respect to personal boundaries.
It uses the term interpersonal relationships, which I think is very similar to that and certainly a big step forward.
And Representative Ladd also has a new section on personal finance literacy, which I think is very strong.
Okay, I will address the 0942H.
Thank you.
What we've done is that we're recognizing this section of law, 189 colon 10, which is in your statute studies, which deals with various studies that go on K through 12 in our schools it references physical education wellness and our physical education in health primarily now and various issues within it within education 306 which are our rules dealing with the standards standards for public school approval, minimum standards, it speaks to health and wellness throughout.
It's a terminology that's been used by the State Board and by the Department of Education prior to 2015 and going forward to this date.
So wellness should be brought into that.
You're going to see the same terminology in 1761.
So both bills have the term wellness.
Both bills have fiscal education in there at the top.
This bill also has personal finance literacy, whereas it's mentioned in when we want to have in the area of a content of an adequate education, and you have to look at the amended version of 1761.
It's not at all what we had introduced.
1761.
16!
1671.
Yeah, I'm tired.
And all subjects are treated the same.
All subjects are part of adequacy.
And we've had the New Hampshire Bankers Association, the Business Industry Association, pushing heavily for personal finance literacy as a learning area, a learning domain.
We're not calling it core anything.
It's just a learning domain, which needs to be taught, just not in the economics course, to be included within economics as it's stated as a graduation requirement right now.
But it needs to be taught, as some schools are doing right now, and wonderfully that they're doing that, and certain banks are also contributing to the curriculum for personal finance literacy.
One up my neck of the woods is Posumptak Bank, which is out of Littleton and across the river in Vermont.
They provide support to students.
In fact, they do matching funds for students.
You put in 50 bucks, we match into a savings account.
Pardon me?
Mary and I worked on this one for many, many a day.
And so personal finance literacy really does belong.
But when we put it into the area of those learning domains or what we call subjects, in adequacy, you don't want to start talking about how it should be done.
That comes down in the studies area.
And we know it can be embedded into things like economics.
And we can know it can be embedded in many different courses.
And that's the way it should be done because it should intertwine with economics, with mathematics, with social studies, etc.
So I've included this area in here which says the school board shall ensure that personal finance literacy instruction designed to prepare students for success in making financial decisions is taught as part of the curriculum.
Personal finance literacy may be embedded in an existing course or grade level program of studies.
And in the content bill, you're going to see that doesn't go into effect for a full year.
It wouldn't go into effect until FY24.
It gives the schools a whole year to prepare and get ready for how to insert this into their content area of adequacy.
So that's been inserted in there.
Also, in looking at the bill, as Representative Tanner gave this us, I think we all understand we can't be saying, you're going to teach 25 minutes of this and 30 minutes of this.
That's where we were back when I started as a teacher back in 1970, after I came home from Vietnam.
And it was for every subject.
You had to do 35 minutes of this and mathematics, reading, literature, and all that.
And then we started doing thematic teaching where it was integrated.
You could be doing reading and social studies concurrently.
So how do you match all those minutes up?
You can't do it.
So every school is unique.
Every school is different.
So the minute thing is gone.
But there's also parts within what was in that bill, which we were dealing with areas of, that's, I've got in here, which we address prevention of sexual violence, which is needed in our society.
and that's in the amendment what I have and I believe that I saw that in the bill that was presented by Representative Tanner.
And I know it's in there.
I just, you know, can't place it.
And I thought that was important to lift that out and put it in here.
And also to have these relationships where people learn how to have relationships with each other interpersonal relationships and so that's the difference I think between the two bills here I think the one amendment includes that personal finance literacy and the reference to sexual prevention violence which I think should go in here where we talk about HIV, where we talk about other issues which we have in our society physiology, hygiene, health interpersonal relationships, that's all good stuff so that's it I'll open it up to discussion on the amendments amongst the committee yes, Representative Luno so thank you Mr.
Chair Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
No, I very much support the amendment you're offering, 942.
I think it's more comprehensive by the fact that it offers prevention of sexual violence and the personal finance literacy sections.
I sort of marginally like the terminology for healthy personal relationships and respect for personal boundaries, but I think both those things are wrapped up into your phrase of interpersonal relationships.
I would be fine to just move forward with the chair's amendment, given the hour and the amount of work we have left to do, if the chair's good with that.
Well, I'm fine with it, and it's just not all my work.
I know that the idea of interpersonal relationships came from the man with the hand up over there, Representative Ford.
Thank you.
interpersonal relationships came from the man with a hand up over there represent ford your mic you red button just another on word choice we were I noticed in the copy I have here it refers to pupils and I was wondering if we might get consistent on our use of students or whatever for all levels of I mean, before spoken to the idea of people being K through 12 or K through 6 or something like that and and just be consistent on that throughout these bills that's all yeah that's something that we're going to change throughout the entire statutes that we have students are referenced to higher ed okay pupils are K-12 or actually it's pre-K through 12th grade.
I'm not saying one or the other.
I'm just saying be consistent.
But we've got to get consistent.
What you see most of in the area we're talking here is the word pupil.
Okay.
So, yeah.
I don't have the, here's the word pupil okay so so yeah I don't have it here's the gavel do I hear a motion from the chair yes I'd like to move off to pass on 1263 a bill dealing with health fiscal, wellness, and personal finance literacy in schools.
Second.
Second, Representative Luno.
Discussion?
Yes, I'd like to move Amendment 0942H ought to pass to 1263.
Representative Cornell will second that.
Any further discussion on the amendment no but I think we're gonna have to wait for the clerk a little bit here yeah that's what we're gonna do now that's what we're doing right now okay on the 0942 amendment.
0942.
Thank you.
Representative Ling.
I'm sorry.
I just thought we were going to raise hands for the amendment.
I was getting ahead of myself.
Sorry.
So all those in favor of 0942H amendment?
That looks to be 19-0.
Thank you.
0 9 4 2 H amendment looks to be 19 0 further amendment I'd like to move out to pass as amended HB 1263 Pot to pass as amended.
Second.
I'll second that.
Any discussion?
Move.
Yep.
as amended second i'll second that okay any discussion so yeah that was oh nine seven four this time oh nine no oh nine i'm gonna go with the same one yes it's oh nine four two h okay no no no, no.
Can't do that.
You're our backup.
Representative Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Lang.
Representative Lincoln.
Yes.
All right.
Sorry about that.
The cell is or wherever I say your name, I apologize.
Yes.
Representative Hopson.
Representative Ford.
Yes.
Representative Sodai.
Representative Nelson.
Yes.
Representative Luno.
Representative Willard.
Yes.
Representative Cornell.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Willard.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Ellison.
Yes.
Representative Mullen.
Representative Mary.
Yes.
Representative Porter.
Representative Hall.
Yes.
And Representative Ladd.
19-0.
Consent, I assume it's okay?
Okay.
Thank you, up top.
Should we get that one out of the way?
Ready with the amendment?
Yeah.
Okay.
How about if we go down and just tackle 1671 now?
We could do that.
We've got the amendment.
1371 is a quickie.
You think it's a quickie?
Let's see.
Okay, let's do 1371.
That should be a cookie.
It should be.
Okay.
okay okay 1371 is a bill relative to school district policies on facial mass of students in schools representative Cordelli thank you mr.
chair I would move ITL on 1371.
Is there a second?
I'll second.
Okay.
Representative Cordelli, would you like to speak to your motion?
Thank you.
We have two bills regarding facial coverings or masks.
I think that this bill treads into the bullying discrimination area.
I think that is not needed and that our bullying statutes, I believe believe are quite comprehensive and I think would cover any incidents related to bullying and harassment of a student because they were or were not wearing a mask so for that reason I don't think that this bill is is needed represent Luna I agree with representative Cordelia don't have anything else to add open to the committee not see any hands are you ready yes sir Representative Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Lang.
Representative Bowen.
Yes.
Representative Lekas.
Representative LaSalle.
I'm going to kill it.
Sorry about that.
I'm going to make you suffer.
Yes.
Representative Hobson?
Representative Ford?
Yes.
Representative Sodai?
Representative Nelson?
Yes.
Representative Luno?
Representative Wellner?
She left.
She's left.
Okay.
Representative Cornell?
Yes.
Representative Tanner?
Representative Ellison?
Yes.
Representative Mullen?
Representative Mary?
Yes.
Representative Porter?
Representative Hall?
Yes.
And Representative Lapp?
Do we have some name changes for people?
Simpler names.
You'll get used to it.
For months, I used to call Representative Woodcock, Representative Woodside.
Yes.
Thank you.
That makes me tell.
So you're good to go.
We understand we're picked from the Farm League today.
Just call me Dick.
There you go.
That's it.
I think 18 and I said.
Yep.
I'll sit on my own.
Are you ready to go on 1141?
There you go.
That's it.
Yep.
Are you ready to go on 1141?
But I answered the most in the morning.
We can do 1164, too.
Yeah.
Egg in the classroom.
There's a few more we can do.
Yeah.
I was saying we've got Bonnie here.
I don't know if you want to do 11 Yeah.
Assume that's on consent?
Yeah, she's been sitting here.
Okay, so we're going to go ahead with HB 1141, relative to special education services for children in charter public schools.
Okay, 1141.
Really?
Yeah.
Everybody, I'd like to take a moment of silence right now.
It was just confirmed that Rene died today.
And so would we all please stand up and take a moment of silence.
Thank you very much.
We've just lost too many good people this year, and my heart is just breaking.
Let's take a 10-minute break right now.
For everybody, just try to collect yourselves.
I know this is a shock to all of us.
When we're in the House here, when I first met Terry Norelli, she indicated to me, Rick, when you get out of here, you're going to remember just not Republican and Democrat.
You're going to remember all the reps that have been with you, and you've come to know some as real close friends and family, and we just lost a family member, and it's hard to take.
Thank you.
Thanks, Rick.
member and it's it's hard to take thank you for letting us know did that just happen today right now?
What's up?
Did that just occur?
Yeah.
Yeah, the speaker just confirmed it.
Oh, no.
Oh, geez.
I heard that the other day in my interview, I asked him to sit.
Thank you.
Okay, we're going to go ahead and reopen this executive session.
and we're starting out with HB 1141 1141 relative to the special education process for individualized education programs IEPs and represented Cordelli do you have a motion that works going I would like to offer a motion of ought to pass.
Is there a second?
Okay, Representative Nelson seconds that.
Representative Cordelli, do you care to speak to your motion?
Just to offer an amendment, if I might.
Okay.
It is amendment 0961H that I think went around.
Okay, you're offering 0961H as amendment 2-1141.
Is there a second to his motion?
Representative Ford makes that second.
Representative Cordelli, would you like to speak to the amendment?
Yes, thank you.
This amendment makes several changes, and I can just walk you briefly through that.
down on the first page in the area of line 23 it adds new paragraphs beginning with roman 4 it leaves in place roman 3 currently which had been previously removed in the prior amendment.
Roman 3 related to short-term objectives within the IEP.
Roman 4 and 5 remain the same as in the previous amendment on second page line seven to nine rulemaking is to be consistent with federal law and this chapter being special education in state law.
And down on the bottom of page two, in bold, in subsection G, discusses the agreement from mediation and states that the agreement shall state that all discussions that have occurred in the mediation process shall be confidential and shall not be used in evidence of any subsequent due process hearing or civil proceeding.
And then over on the next page, on lines 3 through 10 or 11, it indicates that discussions that occurred during the mediation process shall be confidential and shall be not, which actually might be a repeat.
but the next in line eight excuse me nine parties to mediation process shall not be required to sign a confidential confidentiality pledge or non-disclosure agreement prior to or as a condition to commencement of the mediation process which is consistent with federal law if there is an agreement reached in the mediation process then according according to federal law, you can then, as part of that agreement, indicate that the discussions within the mediation process are confidential.
But you cannot require that going into the mediation process.
And I know that there is a current form that the department has that in the agreement to go into mediation, it has one provision in there that was questioned because it says that discussions are confidential and I think that that might be the source of some problems so to be consistent with federal law I don't think that that should be in there the agreement about confidentiality is signed as part of the agreement if there is an agreement made in the mediation process there was another section in the amendment that related to special education that I did not think was necessary anymore.
So that was removed in this amendment, 961.
Excuse me, yeah, 961.
So I think that those are basically the changes that were made in this amendment represent porter or excuse me hold on one second there was a second uh do you have any uh discussion mr this is just the amendment oh that was you.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you, Representative Cordelli.
I was not able to be here for the original hearing last week, so I didn't get a chance to ask my question here.
I'm wondering if you can tell me when the reason why, this seems like a pretty big change to the way things have gone on, and I'm wondering if you did this in consultation with members of the special ed community or organizations that work with those folks, and if they felt that these changes were needed and that's why you brought forth this bill.
I brought this forward after hearing from members of the special ed community Thank you.
I brought this forward after hearing from members of the special ed community during the fall study committee that we had, and a number of problems that we heard from parents in that that I tried to address in here were, one the non-disclosure provisions.
Two, I think the main other one was intimidation was felt by parents with the presence of lawyers in the IEP.
And so that's in here as well.
and the amendment relates to federal law in terms of who are valid participants in the IEP meeting and I do not believe that lawyers in any way qualify as participants according to IDEA de a years ago my husband worked as a parent advocate from the for the parent information center which helped parents work through issues related to IEP and special ed and I'm wondering if you worked with that organization while you were bringing this forward.
Sorry.
I have talked to someone in the Parent Information Center.
Not the organization itself.
Just one person.
One person who is a parent advocate there.
Thank you.
Further discussion?
Yes, Representative Mullen.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair, and thank you for taking my question.
Representative Cordelli, as you know, I sat on that study committee with you, which was the sort of handheld piece to House Bill 581.
That study committee's recommendation was basically for a performance audit, and that audit has not been completed yet because the request, the report was filed November 1, and though I have spoken to Senator Reagan about it, and I understand that the scope of that audit has gotten broader since we met as a committee.
This seems, I know that we requested a side-by-side at the hearing, and the side-by-side is a volume of information in and of itself.
And now in the 11th hour, and that's no fault of your own, Representative Cordelli, you are not in charge of whether or not today is March 7th or March 17th.
So I won't hang that on you.
But for this to...
Yes, yes, here it comes.
So for this amendment to come in today when we have already mentioned about 100 times that we're under the gun and that things requiring lengthy discussions and close examination and how are we going to accommodate that and make room for it, is there any easy way for this document to now be compared to the side-by-side so that members of this committee and anybody watching would actually be able to say, this is in and that is out.
I mean, I know a fair amount about special education, and I don't feel that I have the adequate time right now to look at this amendment and make any kind of a cognizant judgment about what's what's good about it and what I might not agree with thank you yeah I put together this amendment based on the public hearing we had on the 25th and it was not completed by OLS until I think after maybe some of the side-by-side work was done by by our assistant director is everybody aware that you do have the side-by-side handed to you today?
That was for the, yes, exactly right.
But that information has been provided by Jennifer Fore.
Representative Tanner?
I can't express how much I really agree with Representative Mullen.
I, as a classroom teacher, didn't have the ins and outs of special education.
I was involved in some of the meetings, and certainly from being on this committee committee I know some.
But I am just overwhelmed with the information not only in the packet from Gen 4, but then the amendment that we recently had.
And I've been talking with Ms.
Dunham in the audience when we've had some breaks.
And I know she is like right up on things.
And she has some concerns about the amendment and also about the comparison sheet.
So, you know, I would love to have the ability to look at these things and also the ability to have some people who work with us day in and day out and are experts in the field, or at least they're really up on it, to come and talk to us about this rather than, I'd feel terrible voting on this and then having some unintended consequences or maybe some intended consequences that I didn't agree with.
So, you know, I know we're rushing, trying to rush through things, but I don't think this is the place to rush.
The side-by-side, which we got from Jen, is 17 pages in length.
We know that we did have that.
I was on that subcommittee also.
I worked with Representative Cordelli and Representative Mullen and John Reagan.
And we do know we've asked for a performance audit, which I think we're all looking forward to seeing the results of that.
Because there was a need for a performance audit.
There's absolutely no question.
We all concur on that.
So I guess we have to make a decision here whether do we have enough information or understanding of all this that we can move forward at this time or is this a a concern an area of education which is extremely important that we put it into some kind of a study the only option we have is interim study right now but i i don't believe it should be at all.
This thing should not be done that way.
This has real implications for students and parents, school districts, special ed teachers, all involved.
And it's very, very complex, believe me.
It's mind-boggling in terms of how special ed works.
so Representative Cordelli do you have any suggestions as to how you might want to see this It's mind-boggling in terms of how special ed works.
So, Representative Cordelli, do you have any suggestions as how you might want to see this treated right now?
My preference would be ought to pass, but I understand what the representative said.
There are some shifts in this, in that rulemaking in the past has gone well beyond state and federal law without any legislative input.
And to me, that is a huge problem, especially when it deviates so drastically in such an important area for kids.
And I think it's important that we address issues when parents are feeling intimidated by going in to try and get services.
And also when they're forced to sign documents that appear to be in conflict with federal law.
But I would be willing to withdraw my motion and offer a motion of interim study.
But I definitely intend to pursue this area.
Representative Mullen.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Representative Cordelli, I agree with you that there are areas that are necessary to be looked at.
We heard from parents who deserve not only to have an opportunity to speak but to be heard.
But as is the case with Rome not being built in a day, I just think that if we're cautious as we move ahead and make sure just that everyone who is voting on these measures has a thorough and confident understanding of what they're voting on, then I think it's going to make it a whole lot easier to get consensus on these issues.
Further discussion?
Yes, Representative Luna.
Thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
I agree with much of what's been said with respect to the process that this should go through in terms of making sure that everybody knows what they're voting on and that we're at least supporting something that's robust and durable and will improve the opportunities for students and the access for their parents.
So I would support moving this to interim study to give us time to really understand this, I think, much better.
Like it's been said, Ms.
Forrest's side-by-side is 17 pages long on this, so there's a lot to digest here, and there's a lot we can get wrong, or at least with unintentional consequences.
I hate to overuse that term, but we can't afford to get this wrong.
So I would support us if we could reverse the current motion and move something in a process that includes interim study and includes a lot of the groups that I think have indicated that they'd like to be involved in the discussion here.
Representative Ford.
Thank you.
They didn't have any information.
And so for me, these are all niceties we're talking about right now.
Oh, I want the final word.
I want to dot the I and cross the T and all that sort of thing.
But when it comes down to a school system which does not understand it has to obey the law in implementing these, they're going to go on disobeying the law to so-called give the person, the family, whoever's involved their right in an IEP.
And I think to a certain extent, we're just pushing it down the road.
It's more urgent than that.
People's lives are being very much messed up by their failure to follow this procedure.
So I don't know whether it means we should go ahead at this point or interim study, but if we interim study, I would urgently request that we interim study in a hurry.
Thank you.
Well, if you interim study, let me explain that process.
We will have to issue a report by November of this year, and it's either up or down with legislation.
And our thoughts are maybe concerns or recommendations to go along nothing will come out of it until a bill is put forward following this bill other words this is just a catalyst for study interim study for many many bills is just like represent bones often times said a soft polite way of saying it's not going to go anywhere.
We've had several interim studies committees which have been very instrumental in bringing about change in other topics.
We've done that with concussion injury.
We've done it with a number of areas.
We did it with dual and concurrent enrollment.
So if we have people that are actively wanting to be on a study committee and put in the time, it means you don't work during July.
We're not allowed to come in here in July.
But that is so in terms of interim studies.
I know the commission we were on last year, we worked almost every week, twice or three times a week, and that was just tiring.
So before we go interim study route, I want to make sure there's people who actively participate on it.
Secondly, we're looking at another concurrent report going on right now where the performance audit.
And I don't know any  I haven't been given a date myself from John Reagan when that should be done or from those people as well, but I understand, as I heard earlier, it's all expanding.
So that means there's going to be some meat and depth come out of that, and will result in legislation as well I understand I sat on this committee here and I saw the parents come in and we all did and we're all very very concerned and this may or may not help I can't answer that so Representative Cordelli you know I think that there's several ways of doing it, and I'm kind of siding now with let's go forward with the study.
But I'd like to have your recommendation.
You're the one that's put forth this bill.
Yeah.
As you mentioned, there is the performance audit.
The last I heard was that they were going to have the scope of work done this month so when they would actually start the performance audit I think would be sometime in the third quarter there is however a bill over in the Senate that passed unanimously out of the Education Committee has bipartisan support of the Senate and was on the consent calendar, passed on the consent calendar that will be coming to us after crossover.
and the the purpose of that bill is to create an independent office of the advocate for special education so it'll be set up similar to there's an office of child advocate right now this would be an office of special ed advocate and it has a full slate of bipartisan senators as sponsors on the bill so that will be coming over to us and that might be something if we pass it out of the house and get it signed by the governor might provide more rapid relief to some issues than waiting for another bill next year.
I think that's a strong recommendation.
I think that's very logical that we use that vehicle as an instrument to accomplish what we're trying to accomplish here if we don't have something that comes out of the audit.
Or hopefully we would and we'd be able to use it as the vehicle to get the desired end we want.
So at this point in time then, Representative Cordelli, are you willing to pull pull your motion yes I withdraw my ought to pass motion and offer an emotion of interim study and the seconds willing to pull okay so now we have a motion on the table for interim study put forth by represent Cordelli and second by represented Porter.
We've had a little bit of discussion on that.
Is there any further discussion from the maker of the motion or the second?
None.
So Representative Nelson, are you up with us?
Yep.
Let's go for it.
Good.
Representative Cordelli.
Yes.
Representative Lang.
Thank you.
I'll remember sometimes.
Representative Boehm.
Yes.
Representative Leacus.
Representative Lascelles.
Did I get it right.
Yes.
Representative Lucas.
Representative Lascelles.
Did I get it right?
Yes.
Representative Hopson.
Representative Ford.
Yes.
Representative Sodai.
Representative Nelson.
Yes.
Representative Wellner.
I'm left.
I'm sorry.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Wellner.
Left.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
Representative Luno.
Yes.
Representative Wellner.
Left.
Representative Luno, I'll do you last.
Okay.
That's true.
Representative Cornell.
Yes.
Representative Tanner.
Representative Ellison.
Yes.
Representative Mullen.
Representative Mary.
Yes.
Representative Porter.
Representative.
Yes.
Okay.
Consent.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yeah.
So we could do, you know.
I'd like to get 1671 taken care of today.
Get some of the hard bills done.
Okay, we're going to go do 1671 at this time relative to the content of an adequate education.
There's an amendment right here.
I have 18-0.
Did you get one with three holes in it?
Yep.
Let's go that way.
16-71?
I don't go back that far.
Yeah, that's right.
There were a whole slug going this way too Okay, I'd like to go ahead so we can save some time and use it wisely.
1671 is a bill that deals with the content of an adequate education.
And the amendment you received here replaces all of the bill.
So you might as well be looking at the amendment.
And I'll walk you through this amendment right now, the way it reads and the way it is.
It has lines on it, so I'll go down by the lines.
Lines 5 through 8.
There's two changes in lines 5 from 8.
That's original language right out of statute.
But the changes are where it says beginning in the school year 2008-2009.
And we've inserted and for each year thereafter.
So it's inclusive going through now.
Okay, the specific criteria and substantive educational program that deliver the opportunity for an adequate education shall be defined and identified as the school approval standards in the following learning domain areas.
The added language in that is learning domain.
Core is gone in the learning domain areas.
And then below that, you'll see items 1 through 10.
These are those areas.
English, language, arts, and reading.
That's the way it is now in law.
Mathematics.
Mathematics, that's the way it is now in law.
Science, that's currently in law.
Social studies is in law, and we've added following social studies, including civics, government, economics, geography, and history, those five major domains within the area of social studies 16 or excuse me online 13 arts education but that's also been changed it's never before included music which is definitely a area of knowledge and skills that our children should know so it's now arts education including music line 14 is unchanged world languages line 15 which read health education analysis health and wellness education that's as I mentioned earlier today is reflective of what we have currently in the ED 306 including a policy for violations of RRCA 126K colon 8 1a that is in law right now that deals about disseminating cigarettes and things to students that's not what we want we We want to eliminate smoking.
So that's in law.
No change.
Physical education on line 17.
No change there.
18.
Where it says engineering and technologies in law now.
It's added including technology applications.
The use of that.
So that's where we're burying the computer sciences now because computer sciences is something that's really taught in higher ed and what we're doing is computer now is a tool which we use for researching for communicating in language arts for for writing or that way for spreadsheets etc etc so that came about as a result of my working with one of the reps right here on this particular two of the reps which are on the ones not here right now line 10 introduces personal finance literacy which has been requested for years by like mentioned the Bankers Association and business industry is Thank you.
Line 10 introduces personal finance literacy, which has been requested for years by, like I mentioned, the Bankers Association and Business Industry Association of this state.
And it's been an item on the floor of this house for many, many times since I've been in the house for the last 14 years.
Going on down, this section right here, 20, this is on line 20, and it's item B, 1B.
Teachers shall use academic and applied instruction to teach the learning domain areas under paragraph A.
So it's the learning domain areas.
It's not any core areas, anything.
The following skills shall be integrated into the learning domain areas.
Digital literacy, that we need to do.
Digital literacy was something we had in HB 242.
And logic and rhetoric, thinking and communication skills.
Then going down to part two, the new subparagraph here you see in line 25, under definitions, okay, we have applied learning.
Applied learning means an education approach whereby students have the opportunity to directly engage in learning activities using knowledge and skills.
logic there that was in 242 as is that.
That's just a duplication from there.
And rhetoric means the skill of speaking and writing as means of communication or persuasion.
You notice that rhetoric says F because A, under this section, is the minimum standards for public school approval.
That's still there.
B is the academic standards, which is in statute right now.
It means what a student should know and be able to do in a course or at each grade level.
That's in law right now.
As the definition of minimum standards is, minimum standards for public school approval means the applicable criteria that public schools and public academies shall meet in order to be approved school as adopted by the State Board of Education through administrative rules.
That is in law.
It's not here because there's no sense to repeat it.
So A and B and C.
You notice there's no C either because C is already in law, and that's the definition of curriculum.
Curriculum means the lessons and academic content taught in school or in a specific course or program.
That's in law, so there's no need for the writers to put it in here.
It will be there.
It is there.
So then we add in the logic, the rhetoric, et cetera.
Going on to the back on page two, there's another section, accountability for the opportunity of an adequate education we have various sections when in statute right we have the delivery of an adequate education with a costing of an adequate education we have accountability for an opportunity for an adequate education this is amending to read as follows the language all remains the same a school shall demonstrate that it provides the opportunity for an adequate education for the school approval standards as set forth and rules adopted by Department of Education the following areas that's in law and you can see English language arts and reading that's not bold type because that's in mathematics science and then what we do is we replicate everything is up on 1a so we're having accountability accountability for all those content areas which have been there and those several areas which they've been modified.
And lastly, on line 21 on page 2, where it says application, personal finance literacy, which we dealt with today already in studies, the requirement in RSA 193E2A1A10 that is the requirement on the other side which is item 10 personal finance literacy on page 1 references back there as inserted by this act for an adequate education to include the learning domain area of personal finance literacy shall not apply until the 2023-24 school year.
So it gives one year for everybody to gear up for how we're going to integrate, how we're going to teach, how we're going to have that in our curriculum, personal finance literacy.
This act shall take effect 60 days after its passage.
So basically, there's no change in format.
It doesn't mess with the minimum standards for public school approval.
In fact, it supports that, but it even strengthens those areas in the content, which we consider part of our adequate education, and adds in things like music, wellness, and personal finance literacy.
So that concludes this entire bill.
It's not that lengthy a bill.
It's one which I think just adds to what is that content.
And doesn't speak to core, doesn't talk about breaking anything out, doesn't say that public school approval is needed to have these courses.
No, it's all part of adequacy.
And if you look at the statutory judicial references under this section of law, you will see that there was a court statement made by the Claremont decisions back in the 1990s where it says that an adequate education is not merely reading, writing, and arithmetic.
It's all these areas which go beyond and strengthen the knowledge and skills have to walk out of school with.
So hopefully we'll move this thing forward and strengthen what we identify as an adequate content of an adequate education.
Thank you.
They take care of that.
All the stuff where you see they left an S off or something like that's taken care of.
When it's reviewed, yes.
If you keep signing the law.
After it passes the Senate, then it has to go back for review by the President of the Senate and the Speaker.
They checked all this stuff out.
Okay, do you want me to go ahead?
What's that?
I'm not really running that.
I mean.
Do you want me to take the chair?
mean well let me let you once you take the chair and that way there won't be any conflict of interest okay we're in discussion any further comments on the amendment correct there's no motion on the table.
Correct.
There's no motion.
Sure.
I have a question on the amendment.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
On page two of the amendment, section three, where we actually sort of ratchet into a different part of the law, so it's the accountability.
Would the additions to the 12 items here require new rulemaking from the department?
For each of those school approval standards.
If you're asking it to me.
Yeah.
I know that when we modified, the last time we did this is when we modified it with computer technology and that.
So that was 2018.
Yeah.
I'm just looking at the annotation.
Yeah, and that's when that occurred.
But like on line 6 on page 2, for the school approval standards set forth in rules.
So each of these 12 standards have rules written around them.
That's how I'm reading this.
Well, health and wellness is already in rules, even though it wasn't in statute.
Right, but it's got to be in the school approval standard set forth in rules.
I'm just wondering if there's rulemaking that's going.
I think the board has that rulemaking authority.
I'm sure they've got the rulemaking authority.
Elsewhere in law, not here, because that would be elsewhere within this statute.
Yes, yes.
But in order to comply with this statute, they would have to go through rulemaking to set the standards that would expand on these areas to include civics, government, economic, geography, history, to include music, add wellness to Standard 7, add tech applications to Standard 9 nine personal financial literacy which is completely new would be standard ten school year requirements I imagine that's the days and hours that that's that's already a requirement for yeah right within that's already within the minimum standards and that that's nothing new right that's nothing new that's already a requirement within the minimum standards.
And that's nothing new.
Right, that's nothing new.
That's already there.
Right.
And minimum credit's required.
That's nothing new.
That's already there.
But these other areas where there's bold, there would be new rulemaking.
I can remember when we amended the fourth year of mathematics, the way we did that, we required three years of math classes specific.
Then we, when I worked at that time with Paul whoather, who was the Deputy Commissioner of Education at that time with Virginia Berry, we recognized that this state needed kids for not getting mathematics as seniors.
So we required that you shall take mathematics every year you're in a school.
This is in statute.
The fourth year, it's done through embedded mathematics in one of your learning domain areas that's approved by the local school board so that that we did without having to jump into this rule business and it's subsequently been added in by believe, the rules are done upon every time we change something.
So they have the authority to do that.
It will be done.
But we didn't write when we put in the embedded math course something specific, oh, you're going to have to do this now by rules that's already there within law I guess I read RSA 193 e colon 2 dash a under section 4 It talks about the minimum standards for public school approval blah blah blah in paragraph 1 Which is all the standards you just changed in the last sentence of that line talks about the fact that the Doe has rulemaking authority to set everything set in chapter 1.
So if you change Chapter 1, they already have in law rulemaking authority to deal under Section 4A to deal with changes to Chapter 1.
And that's correct.
And the changes which we're doing here are areas within these learning domain areas, with the exception of the personal finance, literacy.
Everything else is we've had arts, education, always understood that that could be theater, it could be music, it could be whatever.
I think it's time, it's my personal feeling that I had a music teacher in my buildings, always.
And music was one of the preps that teachers got, but it was was also something the kids needed and in some of the elementary classrooms music was taught ongoing by the classroom teacher that's why an elementary teachers required to take a methods course in the teaching of music I had to do it and I can't hit a tune or anything but except in the shower so oh go ahead I'm not quite yes I'm sorry go ahead representative Hobson thank you thank you for taking my question one of the issues that keeps coming up in emails that I'm getting about this bill is the funding of domains or content areas.
And I wondered if you could speak to that for me.
I can do that.
Yes.
In the bill as introduced, on the first page of the bill as it's introduced, there on line 13 through 15, there's language, which has really sparked a fire throughout this state.
It said, applied instruction, which deepens the student's understanding of core knowledge, learning domains, and work-study skills required for an adequate education, shall further integrate the following areas of applied learning or additional areas of study as determined by a local school district.
So folks are saying, hey, we're going to have to determine this.
Does that mean we're going to have to pay for this or cost for it?
And that language does not appear in this amendment at all.
The amendment is simply language that's already in law.
So as it's written now, this becomes all of it becomes part of content of an adequate education.
It will further supplement and support what we're trying to do with the funding commission study.
Representative Mullen.
I don't think you're allowed to call on me, Mr.
Chair.
Okay.
Representative Mullen.
Thank you, Representative Cordelli.
Can I just ask a question, Representative Ladd, about your use of the phrase learning domain?
we counselor types when you're talking about learning domains we tend to think about the cognitive domain the affective domain the physical when you're talking about learning domains, we tend to think about the cognitive domain, the affective domain, the physical or psychomotor domain.
Is that a deliberate turn of phrase, this use of learning domains?
It's a catch-all, which combines all of the above that you just mentioned.
It's basically, I've always used the word subjects, but you see this in some of the judicial type decisions.
The use of learning domain.
Okay, thank you.
Additional, yes, Representative Hall.
Sorry, question for Representative Ladd.
I just want to make sure, and I think you brought it up initially, and I kind of missed what you said, but are you suggesting that computer science and digital literacy move up to including technology applications?
I mean, I noticed those were wiped out on the second page.
See, that was an area that was initially in this bill and in 242 last year, an area that was supposed to be integrated with all subject areas, the use of computers.
In the discussion I had, I don't want to mention his name, that we were seeing that the computer sciences or studies are usually a thorough study which involves intensive study at a higher education level.
The use of a computer, though, has now become a tool that every student needs to know how to.
And I'll tell you, probably their first and second third graders out there can just hop around a computer pretty well now and that is a tool and it's a tool for research for communicating etc what we need to do though is teach kids that everything on the web if you go to Wikipedia don't don't believe everything you're reading.
You've got to be able to discern between somebody's opinion and fact, against fact, and that's what we're doing with trying to put in logic and rhetoric, logic for thinking, you know, something that's made up.
So computer studies to me is something, the use of the computer is like the pen, pencil, paper, a slide rule that I was brought up with in school.
We didn't put the slide rule down, but I certainly had to use that when calculating, dropping in the artillery in Vietnam until we had the old tube computers come into play.
So it's a tool, and maybe Representative Luno can better explain computers and that.
He's got that type of a degree and background.
I use it as a tool.
So if I could follow up on that.
Well, you know, I'll be open.
The conversation is something that Repsoluno and I had this last weekend, was it?
It all flies by so quickly.
For me, I guess if I could follow up.
computer science to me is like, and I taught computers, so in middle school though, and I would have to say there was a component of computer science in middle school, and there was digital literacy, and there were technology tools, and I see those as different.
Computer science was where, you know, the coding, and so I think by taking it out of there, I'm not sure that it's being replaced.
And maybe, Representative Bruno, you could speak to that.
But I know we saw that as different.
I think computer science and computer programming are two very different things.
I mean, you could look at computer programming maybe as being a small subset of computer science but but really that's that's not where the you know the the mincing of terms like that obviously computer science at a third grade you know instructional level I think would be different than computer science at a master's degree instructional level.
But in any case, you know, I think there's probably more straightforward terms that could be used rather than computer science.
at K-12.
I think digital literacy is a good one.
That includes a whole lot of things.
Could include some basic programming, could include, obviously, use of applications.
I think you've got that in there.
I'm really, you know, I think there's some very good things in terms of what's being added into this, these, you know, I'm not quite sure of the term learning domain because I think that's a term of art that's used differently, is my understanding, but in these sort of subject areas, to use the term that Representative Ladd talked about, might be better.
But I guess I do have concerns.
I mean, I'm going to support the amendment because I think it's a huge improvement.
But there's a lot that goes into, I think, changing the definition of an adequate education.
And certainly, I think a collaborative style to develop it would be very important.
Given the fact that student outcomes in New Hampshire are already among the best in the country, we don't have that level of urgency that I think Representative Ford may have been alluding to earlier in terms of redefining what's an adequate education.
And I do have lingering concerns about what it means when we add, you know, including civics, government, economics, geography, and history, including music, including wellness, including technology applications, and then a whole new area of personal finance literacy, all of which I believe in.
But these are more things that, remember when the commissioner was here, where he was talking about the box, and now you're putting these things into the box, too.
Well, that box now has gotten a little heavier and a little more expensive, which are all things we've all been working on, school funding, but there's also a pending court case.
And now we're throwing more things into the box.
I do have lingering concerns about what the effect of changing that definition during this time is, and I think this is a good first step framework with some really good things in it.
I'm glad we put personal finance into studies.
It's not, you know, it would maybe be looked at differently than the things in the adequacy box.
You know, but I've got concerns.
And particularly, yeah, I mean, I very much appreciate the time that Rick and Mel and I spent, you know, working on this on Friday.
But, you know, to be fair, I think the definition of what's inside that box should go beyond the three kitchens that we were, you know, working from on that Friday afternoon.
And given the importance that it has not just for the 160,000 kids that are guaranteed under our Constitution with the opportunity for an adequate education, but also to the people who are representing the state in terms of making sure that New Hampshire is delivering upon that.
Senator Murray.
Thank you for taking me questions.
So one of the other questions I have around the concept of the learning domain area is sort of in reference to pedagogy and when we're talking about Bloom's taxonomy.
We then also refer to line 27, applied learning.
And so I'm wanting to make sure that we're consistent with the terminology here because when we're talking about Bloom's and we're talking about the interrelationship between it with the learning domain, there are several other levels above applied learning when you're talking about thought.
And so I'm just wanting to make sure that when we're using applied learning that that's not somehow being conflated with pedagogy.
I'm kind of wondering where that came from.
You can find pedagogy also in the statutes.
You can find all these terms.
And one of the problems is that we've used a lot of education jargon and for many folks in the business of education and I've been in it for many many many years I found that and we've tried to narrow it down we used to have educational standards instructional standards academic standards and more and then we started asking in this committee, okay, define what these things are.
We had to strike some of that out because a lot of overlap.
And the introduction of certain subjects that you see there, like in social studies, I'm looking right now in rules which have gone through JALCAR, been approved, and specify required credits for graduation and graduation competencies.
I'm not going to.
I'm looking at government.
I'm looking at civics, economics.
I'm looking at geography.
I'm looking at personal finance.
I'm looking at wellness.
Those are all mentioned in rule already.
Then we should then be supporting that through the other side of the coin that this is part of a content of an adequate education.
These are requirements that we have for students to graduate from a high school that are built from grades K through 12.
So we can get caught up in the jargon of things, but I believe that the areas which are identified here in this content are contributors to what we want the kids to come out of school with and be prepared for the next step.
Yeah, we can quarrel over a difference between a learning domain, a subject, or a content area.
I don't think it's going to make much difference in the long scheme of things here.
Representative Hobson.
Thank you, Representative Cordelli.
Representative Ladd, I can't remember if it was in a private conversation or if it was in our committee earlier.
You mentioned that the Business Industry Association and the, was it the Chamber of Commerce?
Well, that's the BIA.
Okay.
They had approached you and asked you to work on personal finance literacy.
Well, they were very excited, too, to see it in 242 and very disappointed to see 242 go down.
Follow-up, if you could.
excited to see it in 242 and very disappointed to see 242 go down speaking with employers in my district I have heard that this is an issue for graduates coming out of our schools right now and that something needs to be done so I wouldn't I would encourage you to to pass bill.
Thank you.
Representative Porter.
Thank you Representative Cordelli and I appreciate that this amendment much improves the bill that we had last week.
One of my concerns with the original bill and I think I'm having the same concern with the amendment is that there seems to have been well the commissioner told us that he didn't meet with any stakeholders to write up his original bill that the department knew what needed to be in it and just put it in there and I'm I'm concerned that this amendment also has been done you can see by the conversations we've had asking what does this mean and have you thought about this, that perhaps not having other stakeholders involved in changing this area of law, which is very important for our children getting a good education, if this needed to have some input from from other people besides state representatives in Concord and it just concerns me it's something that's very important to me that people who are actually in the field and people who are teaching people who are doing the work have a say in what is important and what in their knowledge and understanding of how learning happens and what's adequate for children is also taken into consideration so I just want to throw that out there I think it's important we include more people than just us here in this room.
Representative Tanner.
Thank you.
So I'm looking in this book that I, you know, wanted to make sure I had this year.
And under 193E2, it starts out with criteria for an adequate education.
And from what I'm reading in this, because it starts out with skill in and knowledge of and grounding in and sound wellness and environmental skills, it sounds more like it was drafted and represented, glad you probably know, more for competencies type thing.
but one of the things that I as I I'm reading through this, and then E2-A is the substantive educational content of an adequate education.
And that seems to be how you've listed yours.
but I also noticed in between here that and was well aware of the committee that was formed to study the Holocaust studies and that under criteria for an adequate education where it was more competency based number four was knowledge of civics and government economics geography history and Holocaust and genocide education to enable them to participate in the democratic process and to make informed choices as responsible citizens.
And I'm just wondering, I know you've got civics, government, economics, geography, and history, but I don't know if you just missed it that, I believe it was just last year that Holocaust and genocide education was added to social studies.
And whether that's just an oversight.
It's not an oversight.
We have a Holocaust.
And, of course, as you recall, when we were down and moving that bill, I was the one that spoke on behalf of Holocaust on the House floor.
That happened the year I think we were down south and doing the legislation.
In 2021, last year, we modified much of this first part in 193E2 with the language that you just moved through some of that, like the referencing knowledge of civics and government and economics and geography and history.
The next step was to try to incorporate this, and you see sound wellness and environmental practices.
That was also added in in the bill, which was kind of an omnibus bill that we had, that we added this into last year.
Some of it was career technical education as well.
To now go to the next step where we add in and we're better defining what social studies is.
If you were to go talk to the National Council for Social Studies or the social studies group, which I have a cousin who is president of it in this state, Steve would always say to me, Rick, why are you just putting down social studies?
Why aren't you putting the things that are the primary themes within it, which are geography?
How many kids need a better lesson than that?
How many know where the Ukraine is?
How many know where Azerbaijan is?
I wouldn't say a whole lot do.
And it's all part of our world, and we're seeing how it comes together right now.
In terms of the other areas of music, that's never been there.
It should be there.
And if you were to talk to music teachers, if you were to talk to the choral teachers, if you go down and talk to the teachers at Keene State, which that school now is being founded upon the liberal arts and theater and music and choral groups, they have 15 Steinways in the school now.
Their emphasis is music.
So we're seeing this occurring, and I don't see anything radical about what we're doing here.
It's just a continuance of those criteria for an adequate education.
We currently spell out under Romans, as was just mentioned by Representative Tanner, 1 through 7.
And then this right here is putting in the content of an adequate education.
And it's not changing a great deal, nothing more than teachers are already doing.
And I think it better protects a content and adequate education by stating this is what we do.
And I don't think it's putting people on overload either.
I was an elementary teacher, fourth grade.
I've been writer of curriculum.
I wrote the main studies curriculum project that's now bought out by Down East Magazine, which is their their social studies for that state and the themes were the same as you're seeing right here first of all I think I support your amendment it's so much better than the underlying bill um my question is just as as you went to the point of with social studies itemizing it out and because last year uh we so much focused on getting civics into social studies with the civics tests and that.
And we also did, as I said, a committee in order to get the Holocaust and genocide education listed specifically under civics in government.
And I think it would be good to include it in the amendment as well.
That would be one thing I would ask that we include.
Thank you.
Further discussion?
I have one other thing to add here.
I'm just trying to find it.
Yeah, we're going to want to talk about this.
Okay, do you have more discussion?
Yeah, a little bit more discussion.
I mean, I think Representative Tanner brings up a very important point that, you know, I could certainly chalk up to personal oversight on this, but something that I think is so important that should be, I mean, it's important to all of us, and it's important to all of us.
and I don't want to say made more important, but certainly given current events of the last three weeks, to have it very specifically be included in the core, in the subject areas that define inadequate education.
And, you know, I think at this point, given that Representative Tanner has brought this to our attention, that we should be as specific about genocide studies as we are all these other areas and not just gloss it over, but clearly articulate it in the definition of an adequate education, if this is even going to have any chance of moving forward.
I just have one more comment here.
If you look at 189 colon 11, instruction in national and state history in government, there are a number of areas which we have put in there when we're teaching this that came as a result of Senator D'Alessandro and myself introducing this legislation back about four years ago.
Thank you.
And we're teaching this that came as a result of Senator D'Alessandro and myself introducing this legislation back about four years ago.
And in it, we're mentioning civics and we're mentioning government and we're mentioning history.
But we then get into the sub-themes, which you can see down below there, an A going right down through H, which are themes that came out of the state of Ohio when we put this together.
There's an emphasis that we need to have here in terms of better defining our content of an adequate education, which that's what we're trying to do, but also later on by putting within studies some of these sub-areas that we're talking about.
It's all important.
It all needs to be taught.
However, the part we're looking at are adequacy.
We're not supposed to be defining getting down into the very nitty-gritty, into the micromanagement of what is computer science or what is this and that.
Besides mathematics, you could put arithmetic, you could put algebra, you could put geometry and all that.
That's not our job.
However, it is when it comes to social studies, we need to be defining social studies.
What is that?
And some people like to glump everything in other states under humanities.
And you'll see that often now.
And it really doesn't define what the content of an adequate education is in terms of the subject areas or the learning domain areas that need to be covered.
And when we get this, we used to have the frameworks in this state, the guidelines, which were guidelines that spelled out the frameworks for each of these subject areas.
That's gone.
And when we asked for all those a number of years back, we were given, for example, what is the framework for physical education?
We were given stuff that was 20 years old.
It wasn't even relevant.
And so the issue of developing curriculum at the state level, it's disappeared, totally disappeared.
It's not there.
So we downgraded everything.
Curriculum instruction is now a responsibility of the local government, not the state.
Look at what we're doing as assessment testing now.
We're only assessing what?
Reading, writing, and arithmetic and language.
We had other subjects in there a few years back, and we dumped that because we weren't assessing.
We weren't doing our job as a state.
So I hope that we don't start saying, well, we're just going to make these broad categories and let it free flow, go at it at the local level.
I think we're going to lose something in this state.
We have always had pretty high achievement in this state, and that's a result that we've had in the content of inadequate education specific areas which shall be part of this and which we shall fund.
And that's critical.
We shall fund them.
And that means we shall fund these areas right here.
You take it out, yeah, it's on somebody else.
Representative Schell.
Yes, when I think of adequate education, I think of being able to contribute to society and to be a good citizen.
And following on to what Representative Luno said, what's happening currently in current events, understanding what's happening or not understanding what's happening is the product of either having or not having an adequate education.
Understanding what ethnic cleansing is or understanding where the Ukraine is and why we have this big train of Russian heavy equipment and the impact of mud season.
What does mud season in the Ukraine have?
and a cursory examination of World War II history, or going back further to Napoleon and so forth.
Mud season has had a dramatic impact on aggressors.
So when I think adequate education is very important in understanding current events.
And either being a good citizen or not being a good citizen comes right back down to adequate education.
And it really brings it to light when college graduates can't put Florida, can't identify Florida on a map of the United States.
That's pretty pitiful.
And we're graduating, in some cases, citizens who can't do that.
So this is, and I'm a sub here, but this is really the core of what I look toward the purpose of this committee, is making sure we have that, that we define adequate education.
and we follow through and we're able to ensure that maybe we do set the standard or maybe everybody else has fallen back and we're just stable.
I don't know.
But I feel that we can always do better in this area.
I substitute at the local high school in Litchfield, Campbell High, and I see this stuff over and over again.
And I see some students who take several arts classes and take no science classes, no civics classes.
And I wonder, are they getting an adequate education?
I'm not sure.
But thank you for indulging.
Thank you.
Any further?
Representative Mullen.
Thank you for sharing your impressions from your work at the high school, congratulations on surviving being a substitute.
It's an admirable position.
I'm going to bring us just back to the brick and mortar again.
When I look at social studies, I see civics, government, economics, geography, and history listed.
When I look at mathematics, I don't see areas of study listed.
When I look at science, I don't see areas of study listed.
My question to you, Representative Ladd, is was that purposeful in listing it in social studies and not listing it in other areas?
And I think what Representative Tanner is saying is that if you use the definition in Roman 5, then it looks like you forgot Holocaust and genocide studies because all of the other things are listed out just like it is in the list in the amendment.
So I, I, it's a twofer.
What about listing out mathematics areas or science areas?
So it's a twofer.
And two, if that wasn't your intent at all, then was it an oversight or was it mindfully done that way?
We're looking at overarching learning domains.
And that when you start trying to break down mathematics, you could go forever on that.
In regard to the Holocaust, within the law, we just introduced the Holocaust into the statutes and put it in underneath an adequate education already at the very front side where you gain these knowledge and skills and understandings.
I don't have that page right in front of me now, but I know you know where it is as well.
536.
Yeah.
And we modified much of this within the last two or three years.
And by adding a subject like we put in, for example, under the knowledge of biological, physical, and earth sciences.
We could have gone into chemistry and natural sciences and all that.
You can keep going, but it's including environmental environmental sciences that investigate the complex interaction of physical, chemical, and biological processes that take place on the earth to enable them to understand and appreciate the world and the engineering, socioeconomic, and geopolitical challenges around them.
That was written by myself in conjunction with the regional coal lab up in Hanover, working with the director there, and in conjunction with Senator Kahn.
I certainly understand that.
I guess what I'm wondering is why does civics, government, economics, geography, and history appear after social studies in the amendment?
Why is the list there?
if it's already listed in the criteria for an adequate education?
It's criteria within the content of these subject areas that we've so noted.
Some are duplicated.
It's just like you see fiscal education mentioned under the content, but you also see it in studies.
It's because a lot of people have written this book, you know, right here, and it's time really to say, okay, we're not going to do anything for two or three years and rewrite this and get the statutes properly written and get the duplication and edit them.
And of course, I think the folks over in legislative services would agree on that.
But I think that what we've got is the criteria for an adequate education.
Those are some of those criteria, those specific criteria within those domains.
And I'm 100% supportive of the Holocaust.
I've been to the museum down in New York City, have taught it, have written curriculum on it, know about Elie Wiesel and Book Night and all the others.
Those we're engaged in, and that's something that I hope all our students have the right to know and do have the opportunity to learn that.
I just know I'm somewhat kind of put back from the standpoint that we're looking at the content here and we're strengthening the content.
It's not there now.
We have put the social studies trying to define that.
And basically that's coming as a result.
We had a task force at the Department of Education, as you may recall, in the area of social studies, which went nowhere.
And so I think it's important we put these subject areas that are within, that make up social studies.
Social studies is a compilation of many things.
And so is mathematics.
We could put like the commissioner wanted arithmetic and mathematics.
That was what I think was being suggested at one time.
But you look at 306, you will see all the different courses spelled out in that.
At what level do we start?
That's purpose of rules as well.
Thank you.
Just one last comment on it.
At what level do we start?
That's the purpose of rules as well.
Representative Tanner.
Thank you.
Just one last comment on it.
We spent a lot of time on the civics test.
And I know you and Senator D'Alessandro did a lot on the instruction in national and state history and government.
And even under that particular thing where it itemizes things, it has, you know, how tolerance, bigotry, anti-Semitism, national, ethnic, racial, and religious hatred and discrimination have evolved in the past and can evolve into genocide and mass violence such as the Holocaust and how to prevent the evolution of such practices.
So it's kind of listed right there.
I just, you know, my gut feeling is that it was important enough that there was a whole committee, commission developed that came with a recommendation and then it came in as an RSA, that if we're going to itemize social studies, and we're going to put civics because the civics test was something that we, and talking about civics, and not that I don't agree with this stuff.
I think it's really, really important.
I just think it's equally as important that we itemize out Holocaust and genocide education.
So that's just my last hurrah today.
Thanks.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
And I can't agree with Representative Tanner any more than I agree with her on this.
I think really the problem that I see with this, and I think it's been articulated a few times, is the fact that it's an omission and that it's a blatant, flagrant omission.
And it may have been done by accident, and I'll fall on the sword on that.
I was certainly involved with conversations about this.
But because in other places in our statute it uses this phrase and includes Holocaust and genocide studies, that it should not be omitted from here, because I think that omission is meaningful or could be interpreted as meaningful, and none of us want that.
And I think this is sort of symptomatic of what happens in a committee when we get 103 bills and lose almost a week's worth of committee time to get them done because of some changes in the calendar and deadlines.
but but more importantly it also speaks to the fact that such important pieces of legislation like this need to be done in a collaborative way, because if it weren't for people like Representative Tanner bringing this to our attention, and unfortunately it's at, I don't know what time we come in at 4 4 30 on the the the day before the day before we need to have all these things uh wrapped up and we still got a lot more bills to do um it it it wouldn't have gotten caught and and um and you know we we it would have been much better, I think, had we were able to develop this collaboratively with the various stakeholders that support a lot of our other initiatives, whether it's in adequacy, whether it's in special education, whether it's in funding, and been able to do this earlier.
So, you know, and I'm not laying blame or fault to anybody around this table.
We got dealt 103 bills, and we're trying to get through them in the, you know, I cut my teeth upstairs in the Commerce Committee, and I'll attribute it to Chair Hunt, but we can't fix everything.
We do our best, but working collaboratively can hopefully get the job done.
Thank you.
All right.
I would just say that in that same E2 criteria for education where you referenced the Holocaust and genocide education, right above that in science it talks about biology and earth science and so forth, but in this amendment we just leave it at science.
I don't know if we need to go into every aspect of that domain.
But in science, you're not going to any aspects.
This one, you're going into most of them.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
As one of the two House members on the Holocaust and Genocide Studies Commission, I would hope that the wording that's carried forward in a number of places in the existing statute would be incorporated in whatever the final version is that we come up with here.
Representative Ford.
I'd like to offer one other perspective that I haven't heard.
And it's from the college perspective.
I hear us all sitting here saying you have to study this, you have to study that.
Believe me, professors do the same thing.
And they're all urgent.
I don't do...
I hear us all sitting here saying you have to study this, you have to study that.
Believe me, professors do the same thing.
And they're all urgent.
I don't deny that.
But I remember the day a biology professor came down the hall from a class he was trying to teach of teacher candidates.
In Massachusetts, for a course to count toward your certification, it has to have four teachers in the title.
So you get biology, four teachers.
Thank you.
In Massachusetts, for a course to count toward your certification, it has to have four teachers in the title.
So you get biology for teachers.
Somehow their biology is not like everybody else's biology, but that's beside the point.
He was almost in tears because he had an entire class of students, college students, who could not read a ruler.
You hear what I said?
Read a ruler, the very basic instrument you use in measuring for science.
And they didn't know what the two different sides of the ruler meant.
And we're talking about do you have a Holocaust education in a course.
And I'm sitting here thinking of that.
Now that's an exception, maybe.
But just think about it.
When you can't even assume that someone who's graduated from high school knows that there are two sides to a ruler and they measure differently, what can you assume?
Alicia and I have this ongoing conversation about how mathematics is taught or not taught.
And so people don't know how to apply the mathematics.
How can you apply mathematics if you can't even read a ruler?
And I'd be embarrassed to put that in the requirements for an adequate education.
But I know for a fact there's one class in the world, in the history of my life, who couldn't.
We didn't have a great solution for it.
We tried.
sort of pushed back up the pipeline.
Hey, would they need more preparation in this?
But, you know, what impact did it have?
I have no idea.
But there is another side to it.
Thank you.
Yes.
Right.
Thanks, Mr.
Chair.
You know, I'd be surprised if any New Hampshire student fell into that category of not being able to read a ruler, and especially after spending 12 years, 13 years in kindergarten, elementary, and secondary school in New Hampshire.
Certainly our student outcomes are not reflective of that.
I don't even know how to describe that level of performance.
But to somehow equate the most basic thing of reading a ruler with, I think, a much more complicated and relevant to our human existence, Holocaust and genocide studies, is just outrageous.
And I think given the fact that we are enumerating, one, civics government, three economics, four geography, five history under standard four for an adequate education, and leave off in the only other area where this is referenced directly, Holocaust and genocide studies, is now that we've been talking about it, it's in front of us, it's there.
We should certainly adopt that into the definition of inadequate education.
Since we're touching that statute, or since this amendment touches that statute, Thank you.
into the definition of inadequate education, since we're touching that statute, or since this amendment touches that statute.
If the amendment wasn't touching the statute, then we weren't dealing with it.
Or if the amendment wasn't going beyond the comma to include those, what do we say, five areas where it should be?
Six.
Then, I mean, this is something we should look at.
If, Dave, that it's, you know, I think there's not a person at any of these tables which is oppositional to Holocaust and genocide studies.
If, in fact, it's the legislature's responsibility to identify the content of an adequate education.
Flat out, that's what the court system's told us.
Thank you.
If, in fact, it's the legislature's responsibility to identify the content of an adequate education.
Flat out, that's what the court system's told us.
It's our responsibility.
If we see now that it's important to put in, and I agree, I'm not oppositional to it.
We could put in Holocaust and genocide studies in here, in content.
We could change it from learning domain areas to learning areas, if that's more apropos.
To me, it's education ease, and it's more jargon that any teacher's going to read that, at least I, as a beginning teacher back in the 70s, would have said, that's the subjects.
And I'll get a scope and sequence, I'll get the whole thing, and we'll get rolling on it.
And that's exactly what we have to do if you look further in the statutes here and look at room number five.
Under this whole thing, it talks about the pedagogy and all the approaches and all that stuff that if you want education ease, it's there.
So I could come back with an amendment tomorrow with those suggest areas I just mentioned and maybe because we still have a little time here.
If we see something, we'd like to have it included in there.
Thank you.
back to an amendment tomorrow with those suggest areas I just mentioned, and maybe because we still have a little time here, if we see something we'd like to have included in there.
My feeling is anything we do in a content of an adequate education, it's not going to go anywhere until we have some ownership on not just one party, but on all.
And we need to all be in this together because this is what we want our children to have an understanding of the knowledge and skills to be educated.
And so I'm all for it.
I just was very careful, though, in putting this down.
I didn't want us to get into the area, which is the studies area, which we put in the 189 areas that we've just been talking about earlier, and rightfully so, probably eventually we should be putting some of this in there.
But if we want it as the content of an adequate education, it can be done tomorrow.
We can have it there.
See how it goes.
So, Rick, along those lines, what you just said, how we put personal finance literacy under studies, in the studies section, we've got that in there now.
We also have interpersonal relationships.
And we have physical education in there, and we have health in there.
Well, I'm talking about new things that we put in there.
But see, it's surprising that you have certain subjects here in the content which also appear in studies.
Why don't they all appear over there?
And that, I think, would be a good effort for maybe a cleanup, a comprehensive cleanup of these statutes.
That's something we're working towards, and I've spoken with you about trying to get things into the studies areas where they belong, and just that that messed up section of law needs absolute cleanup.
So, Rick, we got hundreds, if not thousands, of emails in opposition to 1671.
Well, that was for not necessarily this area.
I understand.
And the amendment does a lot to do that.
But clearly, 1671 has a reputation out there across the Granite State among educators, among parents, among people who value, and all of us who find public education and the content of an adequate education very important.
It may be that 1671 is just no longer the vehicle to move this forward.
We may be better off just leaving it alone now that we've added personal finance literacy and interpersonal relationships into studies and take this as, I mean, it's something that needs to be done.
It's something that needs to be cleaned up.
It's something that Representative Ford talked about the use of pupils and students, and sometimes we use one, sometimes we use the other.
That may be in here too.
And then, of course, also we've got school funding, which is going to be doing deep dive study and legislation development on that.
handling this at the same time with funding I think makes a lot of sense and not jumping the gun on what's going to be a court case that's heard, I believe, this summer, decided a year from now, and then no matter what the decision is, an appeal, I mean, it's going to go to the Supreme Court and so you know I I just think we could we could put this in the interim study package and and look at this I think that'd be a dreadful mistake it's sending the wrong message out for one to the court system we are addressing, we're looking at finance through a study right now, yes.
And we know that the education funding formula needs a lot of overhaul.
We also know that the court cases have said that it's not a mere study of arithmetic or mathematics, language, and reading.
It's all these things which we have in front of us.
We're clarifying that, and we're also sending the message out, yes, we're looking at this, and we're prepared to try to improve upon what we have, to clarify what we have, but to reject it simply because it has a certain bill number on it, I think is just absolutely wrong.
You know, in our society, we try to teach kids, it's okay to make a mistake.
Learn from your mistake.
And this apparently, you make a mistake, it's dead.
I don't buy into that equation.
I think that we have an opportunity here.
And by not doing anything, we're just going to kick the can down the road farther, and we weren't able to get any resolution out of the task force over at DOE on social studies.
We need to get some resolution here, and maybe it's time for the legislature.
This is social studies.
And it has nothing to do with what's going on in the classroom behind those doors.
It has nothing to do with that.
It has to do with us stepping up to the plate and hitting the ball here.
So, you know, some changes to this, incorporating the definition of learning areas, I agreeable to that.
You know, domain sometimes is, you know, we've got to stop putting language in that's, you know, hard to define.
And incorporating a Holocaust in genocide studies, there's nothing wrong.
That's good stuff.
I don't know how far down we're going to get on this before throwing it in the studies, where it's also stated because we already have established that Holocaust studies will be part of an adequate education.
If you look at the first section of adequacy right here, It's there.
Now we're looking at the content areas.
And what are these content areas?
They're areas of study or subjects.
I don't know.
Because it's not defined anywhere.
Again, I think it's because we're enumerating those areas underneath social studies.
So, Rick, I think having an amendment that adds genocide, Holocaust studies, let's make sure we take it exactly how we use it.
I mean, following what Representative Ford has talked about, let's be consistent in terms of how it's applied in our statute and probably using, I think you used the term subject areas earlier, Rick, which I think is a lot easier to...
Whatever is in the law right now, or he talks in the following...
Areas.
It just says areas.
Period.
That's fine.
I don't think we have to, you see, what's different between a subject, a course, a curriculum?
We've even had that big discussion on instruction, and materials what's the difference you know we're trying to split a hair and education is good at doing that we've had terminology for everything under the sun and I don't think it's gotten us a lot farther along than you know but.
Right, but we're not trying to make it more confusing.
We're trying to make it more straightforward.
There we go.
And that's what this does.
So by making these changes here, I think we even square away what we have in law right now.
And certainly I don't think we should have any problems with, you know, emphasizing rhetoric, you know, and thinking.
My gosh, we've already talked about thinking with shared inquiry this year.
And there's an area that we need to beef up in schools.
Too many people are teaching how to regurgitate rote memory, that rather than taking it and raising it to the level of understanding the meaning of things and sharing that and having an opinion.
We don't do enough of that.
So, hey, if we can give some guidance out there as a legislature, I think that's a great idea.
Let's do it.
I'll come back with an amendment tomorrow.
Representative Hall.
Thank you.
If you just had visual arts and performing arts, and that way it could be music, it could be theater, it could be dance, it could be, so if you do the visual arts and performing arts, just a thought, because you're just singling out music in that.
Some states have it that way.
Some do.
I've looked at it all.
It's all over the board.
Yeah, there's a lot to it.
They're all interpreting it a little differently, but it's a good suggestion.
Anything further?
So we'll recess this.
And we'll have to come back tomorrow and really commit to be here yeah there was no motion actually Yeah, we'll talk about it for today.
Well, yeah, we have a number of bills, which we could do quickly, but we can do them quickly tomorrow, too.
Ag in the classroom.
We're at 9 tomorrow, right?
Yeah.
9.
How many people have to go?
What time are your voting polls closed tomorrow?
7, 7, 6.
6?
They're all over the state.
They're different.
Some at 6, 7, 8.
We open up at 7.
We close at 7.
We're 12 to 6.
Yeah, there's some places that are open just a few hours.
That's some place that only has a few hours in the afternoon.
Yeah, that's right.
He has one.
12 to 6.
Depends on how many people you've got in your town to man the rules.
Yeah, that's right.
Any of you Republicans who want to vote early, I can get you in the list here.
Do they vote twice?
Early in office.
Of course not.
I can get you in.
I'm right by the voting machine.
Hi, Jen.
Bring your own ballot.
I just want to say, Representative Cornell, you want to make some comments.
Oh, I was, oh, yeah, that'd be great.
Four, maybe.
Okay.